aujourd'hui la france oubliée c'est
montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais on vit
tous les jours sans faire attention que
tout en dépend c'est l'unité de mesure
de toute chose une convention admise par
tous
s'il lui arrive quelque chose tout
s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois bien sûr il ya des choses qui
changent bien sûr le monde change
il a d'ailleurs changé entre l'enfance
du général de gaulle et 1969
ce qui ne change pas c'est la condition
humaine et une certaine idée de la
civilisation se fait de la dignité de la
personne humaine et de sa liberté si
vous aviez deux ou trois mots pour
caractériser ce que vous appelez la
méthode l'attitude l'art de gouverner
vous diriez quoi tout d'abord
l'indépendance de la nation
ensuite la souveraineté du peuple et
enfin une perception de la france une et
indivisible
appuyez sur la fierté nationale devons
réapprendre à dire non comme disait
malraux seul l'esclave dit toujours oui
ça la réinfection dessus du bureau de
chaque responsable politique en
particulier de ceux qui se prétendent
des hommes d'état
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi 12 janvier
olivier verront auditionné aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée et au sénat défend bec et
ongles à stratégie vaccinale française
et le choix de la proximité
le ministre de la santé nous les efforts
du gouvernement qui je cite ne navigue
pas vu seulement 1% de variants
d'origine anglais parmi les pcr positif
en france la vaccination elle se
poursuit la ville de nancy devient la
première à faire vacciner les plus de 75
ans or ehpad
l'agencé européenne des médicaments reçu
une demande de commercialisation en
urgence du vaccin développé par
astrazeneca et l'université d'oxford
sa décision sera connue le 29 janvier
outre-manche le gouvernement britannique
exhortent la population à respecter le
confinement face à la flambée de cas le
portugal lui devrait aussi se résoudre à
se re confiné au vu des derniers
chiffres
réponse demain le net
donald trump droit dans ses bottes il
juge la procédure de destitution
totalement ridicule et son discours
d'avant en l'assaut du capitole tout à
fait convenable le président en
déplacement aujourd'hui au texas pour
inspecter l'avancement des travaux de la
fameuse barrière anti migrants
opposition et démocrates prévoit elle un
vote sur une seconde processus de
procédure de destitution de joe biden
sera investie
dans huit jours
[Musique]
mais
olivier ferrand auditionné aujourd'hui
donc à l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
par une commission des affaires sociales
sur la stratégie vaccinale du
gouvernement interpellé par des élus le
ministre de la santé a défendu la ligne
de l'exécutif ont fait le point devant
le palais du luxembourg avec katia
techniques vont soir katia que peut-on
donc retenir de cette journée d'audition
eh bien on peut dire qu'olivier ferrand
a vraiment défendu la stratégie
vaccinale est largué du fait d'une part
qu'elle avait été débattu à l'assemblée
discuter avec les groupes parlementaires
et surtout qu'il avait suivi les
consignes de la haute autorité de santé
alors on se en ce sens c'est bien le
bilan est conforme aux prévisions at il
estimé
mais pourtant ou objecté les
parlementaires et les sénateurs en
particulier cet après midi il ya bien eu
des lenteurs des retards qui rappelle
d'ailleurs les problèmes rencontrés avec
les masques et les tests alors il ya eu
quand même eu des explications
en effet l' agence européenne du
médicament n'avait dans un premier temps
autorisé que le bac somme phison on ne
peut fabriquer des dizaines de millions
de doses en même temps c'est pour ça
qu'il n'ya à date en france a rappelé le
ministre qu'un million de doses il a
donc fait peser la responsabilité sur l'
agence européenne du médicament mais on
rappelle tout de même que même si
l'allemagne et l'italie dispose
exactement du même vaccin et bien ils
ont déjà vaccinées deux à trois fois
plus de personnes olivier ferrand a été
également interrogé aussi bien ce matin
que cet après midi au sénat sur le
recours au cabinet américain mckinsey
pour l'élaboration de la stratégie
vaccinale un cabinet privé on écouté les
explications de financement est pris sur
le budget du ministère donc le budget du
ministère de la santé et des solidarités
d'attenté certainement pas sur le budget
de la sécurité sociale et je encore une
fois je revendique que nous soyons
capables que nous soyons capables de
nous et de nous épauler sur toutes les
compétences ou qu'elles existent sont
des milliers de personnes qui se sentent
parfois pointé du doigt alors qu'elles
consacrent absolument toute leur énergie
keller qu'elle travaillait au sein de
son ministère en dehors du ministère
dans une agence régionale ou nationale
ou qu'elle travaille dans le secteur
privé qu'elle soit venu nous épauler ou
qu'elle vient des armes et autres ce
sont des gens je vous assure si vous
veniez les voir avec moi ce sont des
gens qui travaillent en permanence et
qui travaillent en réseau et qui
travaille bien
alors un recours un qu'il juge comme un
haut niveau européen recours à des
cabinets privés alors à retenir au fil
de jours une montée en puissance de la
logistique avec l'arrivée du vaccin
moderna 500 mille doses supplémentaires
avec un objectif d'un million de
vaccinés fin janvier et puis se
développant sur lequel il a insisté des
petits centres de vaccination centres de
proximité afin d'éviter aux patients de
parcourir des dizaines de kilomètres il
y en aura trois cent cette semaine et 6
ans dès la semaine prochaine
et puis une volonté de transparence avec
la communication chaque soir des
chiffres de la vaccination
merci katia technique en direct depuis
le sénat et pendant ce temps donc la
campagne de vaccination se poursuit à un
rythme bien plus soutenu mais différent
selon les régions
la ville de nancy a commencé ce matin à
vacciner des personnes âgées de plus de
75 ans résidant aurait pas dès cette
semaine c'est cette semaine que le site
d'octo libre viendra compléter le
dispositif vaccinale tant au niveau de
la prise de rendez-vous que pour éviter
de perdre les deux inutilement les
startups maya et ken block sont
également les partenaires officiels de
l'état avec le site du gouvernement
sante.fr à partir du 14 janvier
alors question cette stratégie de
vaccination du gouvernement et elle
maîtrise et comme se défend l'exécutif
le couvre-feu est il suffisant pour
l'instant comme le dit jean castex quid
des écoles avec le spectre du variant
angles est plus contagieux c'est l'objet
de notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes en
direct avec et joëlle mélin députée
européenne identité démocratie médecins
généralistes également bon soir joëlle
mélin merci d'être avec nous laurent
alexandre hezez liste est chirurgien est
avec nous également bonsoir laurent
alexandre merci à tous les deux d'être
avec nous laurent alexandre on commence
par vous qu'est ce qu'on va regarder
votre tweet en même temps vous vous êtes
fait vacciner ce matin est manifestement
vous fait campagne sur les réseaux
sociaux en faveur de la vaccination vont
chercher à convaincre les sceptiques le
vaccin est le seul moyen de se
débarrasser du virus selon vous oui il
n'y a pas d'autre solution nous n'avons
hélas aucun antiviral qui fonctionne
contre le virus ni ni les interférons ni
la chloroquine ni le même désir ni le
pin à bir ne fonctionne donc la seule
solution pour qu'on retrouve une vie
normale qu'on sauve nos aînés qu'on
évite les kovy blond c'est de nous faire
vacciner rapidement et c'est pour ça que
j'ai twitté ma propre vaccination je me
suis fait vacciner par cette remarquable
innovation quel vaccin arn qui donne
extraordinairement peu d'effets
secondaires et qui a une efficacité
formidable et je voulais incité mais
follower les gens qui me suivent à se
faire vacciner le plus vite possible
quand il y aura des doses vaccinales
mais vous savez bien que malheureusement
l'union européenne a commandé pro peu de
vaccins et nous n'allons vacciner qu'à
un rythme entre cinq et dix fois plus
faible que ce que fait par exemple
israël en ce moment il va être le
premier pays au monde à retrouver un
mode de vie normal puisqu'ils ont déjà
vacciner 65 % des gens de plus de 60 ans
et qu'ils auront fini la vaccination de
tous les adolescents de plus de 16 ans
et de tous les adultes entre mi mars et
fin mars
alors vous êtes d'accord on va y revenir
à laurent alexandre parce que c'est
intéressant ce que vous nous dites pas
ce que c'est vrai qu'israël n'a pas payé
totalement les mêmes choses qu'eux que
l'europe sur ses vaccins mais a été
effectivement servi davantage joëlle
mélin vous êtes d'accord avec ce qui
vient
être dit le vaccin c'est la seule porte
de sortie de ce virus sachant et il ne
faut pas les oublier qu'il ya beaucoup
de sceptiques dans ce pays
beaucoup de personnes qui pensent qu'il
n'y a pas assez de recul notamment sur
les études qui ont été faites au sujet
de ce vaccin
alors je vais bien entendu vous répondre
je vais peut-être donné une petite
précision par avance il se trouve qu'il
ya longtemps que je ne suis plus
généraliste mais que je suis par
ailleurs gériatre et que je suis un
ancien expert judiciaire en matière de
responsabilité médicale donc je suis
extrêmement attentive à ce qui se passe
pour répondre précisément à votre
question je pense que dans l'état actuel
des choses et compte tenu de l'urgence
dans laquelle nous sommes malheureux
quelque part malheureusement pour ceux
qui sont sceptiques
il n'y a que le vaccin et je trouve que
monsieur alexandre beaucoup de chance
parce que moi j'ai tenté de me faire
vacciner / vannier et je vais devoir
attendre encore quelques semaines
ceci dit là où j'ai quand même une
remarque à faire c'est que malgré les
sommes tout à fait importantes qui ont
été mis sur la table pour la recherche
et je crois savoir d'ailleurs que
l'union européenne a débloqué des fonds
dès le 31 décembre 2019 par le biais de
la cellule prépare et du comité outbreak
nous n'avons à ce jour aucune étude tout
à fait satisfaisante qu'ils soient
sortis sur les alternatives aux vaccins
j'entends par là on sait qu'il ya des
vieux antibiotiques des vieux anti
inflammatoire qui pourrait marcher mais
nous n'avons aucune étude
et puis aucune étude en toutes celles
qui ont été lancées ont été arrêtés
avant même qu'on puisse prouver que la
chloroquine n'aurait pas marché
donc c'est un peu dommage qu'on n'ait
pas d'alternative pour ceux qui sont
sceptiques en ce qui me concerne je
pense que la vaccination peut-être
qu'elle nous est présentée encore
satisfaisante puisque nous avons affaire
à la rn messager qui est une nouvelle
méthode qui n'est d'ailleurs pas
totalement un bac 5 et une thérapie la
personne vaccinée peut transmettre
encore la maladie mais en fait tout ça
ça nous permettra sans doute d'avancer
et je suis tout à fait d'accord pour
dire qu'en france nous avons un retard
tout à fait conséquents
mais pas que sur la vaccination la prog
mentation de toutes les états qui ont
été dissociées au lieu d'être mises
ensemble à savoir tester d'abord à
empêcher la circulation pas du test puis
l'évaluation et surtout des quarantaines
ils sont maintenant des semaines et les
isolements qui aurait permis
sérieusement de couper la chaîne du
troll de contamination n'ont pas été
respectées quant aux pour terminer là
votre sur votre question le fait de
passer à un confinement à 18 heures
c'est dommage qu'on n'ait pas vu ce que
donnait le confinement à 20 heures voilà
on va faire jouer le mail en restant
dans lord et parlons de ce vaccin va
revenir justement sur ces mesures de
restriction après illustration de ce que
vous venez nous dire est ce que le
docteur alexandre venez de nous dire
précédemment effectivement on n'est pas
vraiment en avance en france première
piqûre le 7 décembre dernier regarder
petit comparatif sur cet écran avec nos
voisins européens et même plus on a fait
un tableau au classement pourcentage de
population vaccinée et vous le voyez un
la place de la france dernière colonne
en bas à droite on est clairement bon
dernier olivier vers ont été auditionnés
nuit aujourd'hui à l'assemblée pourtant
le ministre de la santé a balayé les
critiques sur la stratégie sanitaire
gouvernementale on les écoute avant de
vous faire réagir
nous n'abdiquons pas à vue une stratégie
a été défini par la haute autorité de
santé qui est je le rappelle une
autorité indépendante alors alexandre un
gouvernement qui visait quatre cent
mille vacciner déficit la fin de la
semaine un million d'ici la fin du mois
il faut aller plus vite la prise de
rendez vous notamment pour les mecs en
sueur d'octo lips est notamment l'un des
outils qui va permettre d'accélérer
oui oui je pense qu'il faut aller plus
vite il n'est pas normal qu'il y ait un
million plus d'un million de doses de
vaccins qu'ils soient dans les frigos
ces doses devrait déjà être dans les
bras des gens qui pourraient être
vaccinés comme gelée était ce ce matin
on sait que la protection devient bonne
à partir du 12e jour 11e ou 12e jour
après la première injection
il faut bien sûr faire les deux
injections mais on est déjà forte
mon protégé au goût d'une semaine et
demie après la première
donc ça va sauver des vies de vacciner
vite on l'a dit on manque de vaccination
de vaccins on peut on peut vacciner plus
vite en vaccinant tout ce qu'il ya dans
les frigos
mais de toute façon ne pouvons pas avoir
une stratégie à l'anglais zoua
l'israélienne parce que nous allons
manquer de doses vaccinales
l'union européenne n'a pas pris les
options qu'elle avait pendant l'été elle
a laissé pourrir la situation
pendant pendant l'été et au moment où
netanyahu le premier ministre israélien
appelez personnellement 17 fois le
président de pfizer pour avoir davantage
de doses en payant les doses 40% plus
cher que le marché
eh bien nous ne faisions pas ça l'europe
a été négligente à emmanuel macron et la
présidente de la commission n'ont pas
appelé 17 fois le président des
laboratoires pfizer pour récupérer des
doses l'europe à chipoter sur le prix
des vaccins au lieu de surpayer les
vaccins comme certains pays l'ont fait
et on le paie au prix fort
on aurait mieux fait d'acheter vaccin 50
euros pièce
évitez le troisième rang confinement qui
est aujourd'hui quasiment inévitable au
moment où le variant britannique
malheureusement n'est est loin d'être
majoritaire mais se développe très vite
il y a très probablement déjà des
milliers des milliers des milliers de
gens qui ont été en france contaminée
avec le variant britannique donc la
situation est en train d'être rattrapé
les lourdeurs bureaucratiques insensé
qui avait été mis en place au début pour
faire plaisir aux anti vaccins sont
progressivement
je me suis tapé personnes
personnellement 45 avec un tapage du
guide de vaccination dans les ehpad
je n'ai jamais vu une langue de bois
bureaucratique aussi utile est aussi
longue 45 pages pour expliquer comment
on vaccine des personnes âgées s'est
démis débile et dément et d'ailleurs le
président macro comme le rappelle le
point cette semaine a été abasourdi par
la connerie bureaucratique du guide de
vaccination dans les ehpad et je
conseille aux jambes est intéressant la
politique de de lire les 45 pages de ce
guide
j'espère qu'ils ne manqueront pas joëlle
mélin finalement cette lenteur que nous
décrit laurent alexandre san en arrange
peut-être plus d'un en france puisque
comme le docteur alexandre le souligner
de toute manière nous n'avons pas assez
de doses
la faute à l'europe on aurait dû
peut-être plus haut point pays par pays
de façon à payer peut-être plus cher de
commander différemment mieux cibler les
commandes est ce que on le doit
justement la lourdeur de l'europe selon
vous oui absolument ce matin nous avions
encore une audition avec la directrice
de la dg santé et la direction générale
de la santé à la commission européenne
qui s'insurgeaient contre le fait que
les pays membres de l'europe puisse
envisager d'acheter des vaccins en
dehors des prêts achats groupés qui ont
été faits à la suite des contrats qui
ont été passés et ça il faut bien le
dire dans une forme d'opacité qui en
gêne certains je le comprends très bien
d'ailleurs demain je ferai partie des
quelques députés qui ont l'occasion
d'aller consulter mais dans des
conditions assez rocambolesque c'est à
dire un peu dans des endroits sécurisés
sans téléphone sans crayon consulter
pendant 50 minutes les contrats du
vaccin curve acte qui au demeurant a
reçu énormément gens d'argent de
l'europe ce client au choix était une
bonne chose
donc l'europe a été trop lourde dans
cette fonction qui a été de conclure des
contrats à d'ailleurs je note qu'elle
s'est auto saisie de cette mission en
haut lieu et place en lieu et place des
états ce qui n'est pas une forcément une
bonne chose
et effectivement il ya une lourdeur
sachant que certains états s'en sont
affranchis mais que la france ne s'en
affranchit et par ailleurs je voudrais
noter pour rebondir sur ce que veut dire
monsieur alexandre que à toutes les
étapes de la responsabilité
il y a un vrai problème qui est augmente
scepticisme à savoir qu' il a été dit de
nombreuses fois que les laboratoires se
défausser de toute responsabilité par
avance non pas de la fabrication elle
même là ils sont responsables mais des
aléas secondaire
des effets qu'on ne connaîtrait pas
encore mais je dois dire aussi que l'on
ne peut pas non plus demander un
consentement éclairé à des personnes
quand on ne peut les éclairer sur rien
du tout puisque on ne connaît pas les
effets à moyen et long terme
on connaît bien et c'est là c'est assez
rassurant on connaît bien les effets à
court terme
le vaccin moderna a été comment
dirais-je testé sur l'homme depuis le 16
mars 2020 cd trouve ça quand même plus
d'un an les travaux sur la rn messager
et sur les coronavirus sont très anciens
donc la rapidité de la rn message et ne
doit pas étonner c'est que ce n'est pas
la méthode qui va être celui de sanofi
qui ne viendra qu'en fin d'année
mais pour autant il va bien falloir que
l'on créé le concept de responsabilité
sanitaires des états ça avait été
discutée à propos de madame bachelot en
il faut qu'on remette ça sur la table il
faudra bien s'il ya eu des retards des
manquements ou des négligences que celle
ci soit retenue parce que la perte de
chance à elle mis sur la maladie et on
pense quand même aux 66 mille personnes
décédées mais aussi sur sept vies
gâchées de toutes les générations depuis
un an mais bon on peut dire au moins
depuis six mois puisque nous avons quand
même eu les exemples des pays du sud est
asiatique de l'australie qui nous ont
montré la voie nous n'avons pas voulu
voir ces exemples est véritablement ça
nous pose et monsieur vers on continue
dans une position tout à fait crispé de
ne pas voir qu'autour de lui
la ville voudrait continuer alors que
lui prend des sites il prend des
décisions qui sont toutes trop rapide on
ne laisse pas du temps au temps pour
voir si telle ou telle mesure fonctionne
à maintenant on nous dit passé de 20
heures samedi dans les bouches du rhône
nous y somme de 20 heures à 18 heures
mais on n'a pas laissé le temps au 20h
de prouver que c'était une bonne
solution et du coup on va arriver dans
le confinement généralisée très bêtement
voilà et il faut pouvoir par ailleurs
permettre à tous ceux qui veulent se
faire vacciner de le faire que les
autres veille attendre et bien ils
attendent de toute façon est repassé de
vaccins on a un tout petit peu de temps
mais pas plus que ça il faut que le
virus
arrête de circuler sachant que les
mariant arrive bouscule toutes les
donnes justement joëlle mélin leur
confinement le variant qui sont
directement liés au sujet de l'école on
en a beaucoup parlé aujourd'hui
puisqu'on a appris par santé publique
france que la positivité avait bondi la
première semaine de janvier jusqu'à 10 %
chez les 10-19 ans ceux d'entre eux
évidemment des interrogations et des
préoccupations sur la fermeture des
classes et des cantines mis en cause par
certains l'europe
vous le voyez sur cet écran est scindé
sur cette question regard des cinq pays
qui maintiennent les écoles ouvertes la
france la belgique l'espagne le portugal
et la suisse la suisse d'ailleurs où une
étude a clairement montré que la
fermeture des classes avaient un impact
efficace sur la circulation du kobe de
19 en france e mini de l'éducation lui a
expliqué que la fermeture des classes et
ben c'était vraiment le tout dernier
recours
gorée est ce qu'on doit au moins fermé
les cantines pour renforcer la sécurité
sanitaire dans dans les établissements
c'est la question que beaucoup se posent
laurent alexandre c'est une question
difficile par rapport à d'autres pays
que vous avez indiqué qu'ils ont fermé
les écoles
la france est dans une situation
différente en france le niveau des
enfants a beaucoup baissé ces dernières
années les inégalités territoriales sont
plus forte en france que dans les autres
pays il y a des tas d'enfants qui sont
en décrochage
nous ne sommes pas dans la situation
francs dinard où il ya une assez bonne
homogénéité du niveau scolaire et les
derniers classements il s'agit de pizza
ou des classements science montre que le
niveau des jeunes français s'effondre en
mathématiques et en sciences le niveau
des jeunes français est en train de
s'effondrer dans une société très
complexe où les pays d'asie gagne sans
arrêt des parts de marché si nous avons
des gamins inculte en 2040 ils sont
parfaits de trouver un boulot de qualité
donc effectivement nous sommes face à un
dilemme
l'école peut participer à la diffusion
des variants mais dans un pays la france
où le niveau scolaire des gamins s'est
effondrée depuis 30 ans
fermer les écoles pose un énorme
problème de justice sociale et puis un
problème politique
vous imaginez avant même le confinement
le niveau des gamins s'est effondré en
france que va-t-il se passer si on a un
confinement strict et une fermeture des
écoles
donc oui c'est un choix cornélien est
très très difficile
nous ne sommes pas dans la situation des
autres pays nous avons un grave problème
scolaire et je le répète l'effondrement
du niveau de nos gamins en france et 1
est un énorme problème qui qui rend
difficile la fermeture des écoles et
encore vous fait pas le genre enfin vous
me n'évoquez pas plutôt pardonnez-moi
les problèmes psychologiques qui sont
nombreux entre les pédiatres le relève
joëlle mélin
pour le coup vous suivez la ligne du
ministre de l'éducation qui d'ailleurs
apparemment et en étant division avec
certains de ses collègues du
gouvernement de se dire voilà coûte que
coûte
on laisse les écoles ouvertes et ça sera
vraiment le tout dernier recours un avec
ce débat notamment le disais tout à
l'heure sur sur les cantines qui sont
pointés du doigt vous comprenez qu'on
qu'on laisse l'école en tout cas ouverte
pour le moment pour les mêmes raisons
que monsieur à l'écran alexandre je peux
comprendre que c'est un vrai problème
que de les refermer
mais c'est l'occasion pour moi de
soulever une interrogation que je
n'arrive d'ailleurs pas encore une fois
à 1 comment dirais-je a levé je pense
qu'il y a des voies de contamination que
l'on n'a pas encore recherchés en
particulier la salive et la chaîne des
objets de table par sûrement les verts
et les fourchettes qui sont directement
porter à la bouche ne sont peut-être pas
suffisamment surveillé
j'en veux pour preuve aussi c'est que
j'ai moi monsieur monsieur alexandre a
fait son un effort en faisant les 45
pages du et comment dirais-je du
consentement éclairé moi j'ai fait celle
des quarante et une page de l'umih vous
savez la grande le grand syndicat de
l'hôtellerie il n'y a strictement rien
sur le circuit découvert et des verts en
salle pour l'hôtellerie et encore moins
pour les bars il y aussi un autre une
autre contamination qui n'est pas que la
peau des mains ou la peau du visage
quand on s'embrasse ou quant au seau
touche le nez ou la bouche c'est la
totalité du corps les études japonaises
ont prouvé que il y avait là ça reste le
virus restait sur la peau 8 à 9 heures
et les japonais qui eux ont une hygiène
corporelle tout à fait sur dimensionné
par rapport à nous et bien eux ont très
peu de mort je pense qu'il faut qu'on
regarde aussi qu'il ya peut-être
d'autres voies de contamination que
uniquement les postillons et puis les
mains qui aurait touché la bouche l'on
capté des efforts à faire de ce côté là
peut être pour arriver peut-être en eux
chance à ne pas fermer nos écoles voilà
après je ne suis pas la mieux placée
pour savoir si on doit les fermer ou pas
je serais tout à fait dramatique mais
comme dans tous les pans de l'économie
française et tous les pans de société
jose rappeler quand même une chose c'est
que lors des auditions de septembre une
jeune femme le nom m'échappe à la
seconde a dit qu' une jeune médecin
généraliste a dit que et a bien prouvé
que beaucoup beaucoup de nos concitoyens
avait été retrouvé mort chez eux pas dû
qu'au vide uniquement de solitude et
d'avoir entendu à longueur de journée
des informations extrêmement déprimante
voilà donc il est clair qu'il faut s'en
sortir le plus vite possible
j'incite vraiment les pouvoirs publics
et toutes les universités et dieu sait
quel travail à nous fournir au plus tôt
toutes les études exploitables je sais
que beaucoup beaucoup de gens de talent
travail
je sais que d'autres confrères se
plaignent nous n'arrivons pas à avoir
des études qu'ils soient des études
synthétique nous avons que des tout
petits bouts dernier point aussi il
faudra quand même qu'on s'occupe d'eux
l'origine de ce virus parce que si on en
savait plus sur l'origine peut être
aurions nous de meilleurs moyens pour le
combattre un des inspecteurs de l'om s
sont en route vers pékin actuellement en
espérant qu'ils puissent travailler dans
des conditions de transparence
satisfaisantes merci en tout cas joëlle
mélin députée européenne identité
démocratie ex médecin même si on le
reste à vie n'est-ce pas gériatre
laurent alexandre merci également
essayiste et chirurgiens d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france est
donc quelques instants rester avec nous
reviendrons sur la situation sanitaire
outre-manche le gouvernement britannique
exhortent la population à respecter le
confinement au risque sinon d'alourdir
le bilan humain face à la flambée des
quatre comités puis direction la tunisie
loto de mortalité dans le pays est l'un
des plus élevés dans la région s'alarme
l'om s
[Musique]
ce qu'on attend un peu de vous c'est des
idées pour en sortir est votre jugement
notamment de la façon dont cette crise
est gérée ce qui a été montré au cours
de la gestion de cette crise c'est le
déficit d'anticipation pour moi la
politique c'est d'abord d'être efficace
dès qu'il ya un manque de cohérence
il ya il ya un manque de fiabilité il ya
un manque de confiance faut vite
retrouver la confiance vous considérer
aujourd'hui que que la france a été plus
mauvaise que beaucoup de nos payes et
étrangers nous sommes le pays qui a
inventé les vaccins avec pasteur dont la
réactivité française n'a pas été à la
hauteur de notre réputation tout le
monde a vu que dès le mois de juillet
les chinois vacciner pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a attendu si longtemps
la question est de savoir comment est-ce
qu'on va retrouver un équilibre en
faisant en sorte que les épreuves que
nous subissons actuellement deviennent
des forces et non pas des handicaps
durable
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas un oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir 8e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le royaume-uni va-t-il sortir gagnant du
bric site
nous allons rester voisins et amis de
l'union européenne mais faisons partie
de l'europe
rien ne va changer cela maintenant
qu'ils sont sortis c'est là que les
choses vont commencer c'est pas un point
final du tout les choses commencent au
contraire plutôt que de finir il est
clair que bien qu lieu soit un
partenaire très puissant mieux exporté
bien plus vers le royaume uni comme vous
l'avez dit que le royaume uni vers le
haut il faut bien comprendre que c'est
sur la circulation des biens et sur la
production bien si nous qui sommes
perdants c'est les européens
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française et c'était après les
attentats du 11 septembre
et quand on vient vous voir et qu'on
vous dit écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu que c'est fini pour moi est ce
que je sors mon arme
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du mahler mais
quel est le rapport avec la radiation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
[Musique]
l'auteur 30 heure française souhaité
bienvenue en direct sur rt francs si
vous nous rejoignez le royaume uni est
gravement touchée par le variant
vendredi c'est même un record de
contamination en 24 heures qui a été
atteint londres veut accélérer son plan
de vaccination 2,3 millions de
britanniques ont déjà été vaccinées
prochain objectif les 14 millions de
personnes à risques d'ici la fin du mois
de février
boris johnson parler d'un sprinter d'une
course contre la montre et coûteux il
est plus sage de parler de marathon
plutôt que de sprint nous avons depuis
ce mardi vacciner 39 9 % des plus de 80
ans en angleterre
nous allons rentrer en contact avec les
plus de 80 ans et nous assurer que le
vaccin leur sera administré durant les
prochaines semaines au 15 février nous
aurons vacciner les quatre groupes
prioritaires et pour en parler nous
sommes en direct depuis le royaume-uni
avec bharat pas en khâgne un expert en
maladies infectieuses à l'université
d'exeter c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir baratte en khâgne à merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france est ce
que on peut parler clairement
aujourd'hui une épidémie totalement hors
de contrôle au royaume uni c'est triste
à dire mais effectivement nous ne nous
contrôlons plus l'épidémie le nombre des
cas augmente les hôpitaux se remplissent
très rapidement même si l'on sent pas
encore tout à fait rempli et c'est une
période très préoccupante alors on voit
que le gouvernement n'hésite pas à
agiter le chiffon rouge et durcit le ton
violet confinement coûte des vies
clairement il y a
du mal pour les britanniques à respecter
les règles c'est vrai qu'on a vu
certains reportages on voit pas
forcément les anglais porter de masque
dans la rue la prise de conscience n'est
pas arrivé pink dirigeants lausanne les
femmes politiques n'ont pas voté très
stricte sur ce point il n'y pas été
assez sérieux sur la communication d'un
message très simple
portez votre masque protégez vous gardez
vos distances
c'est simple message non pas des
transmis à ce rapidement
et c'est comme les petits enfants si on
ne les aide pas correctement alors il
est plus difficile de le faire plus tard
clairement le confinement est il
respecté aujourd'hui au royaume uni
l'avis du médecin vous êtes de
l'affectio log locale et le font
malheureusement des postes très strictes
nous ne demandons pas aux gens de rester
à la maison et pourtant c'est une
nécessité il faut rester chez soi et ne
sortir que pour des raisons très
important que nous avons un semis
confinement pour un sit in hier et comme
il s'agit d'un semis confinement il leur
rend plus difficile à deux essais le
nombre des délits tdk donc le
confinement du beaucoup plus longtemps
car il n'est pas totale alors là on
vient de parler évidemment des mesures
de restriction mais enfin l'une des
causes hors de cette épidémie qui n'est
pas contrôlée au royaume uni c'est aussi
ce variant ce variant anglais dont on
parle beaucoup c'est véritablement une
épidémie dans l'épidémie avec ce nouveau
variant les personnes contaminées
relâche beaucoup plus de pathogènes de
particules virales et karel en rejettent
beaucoup plus
alors le virus est beaucoup plus
contagieux
donc nous avons une augmentation du
nombre de cas car il est plus facile de
se faire contaminer
c'est là qu'a failli une autre mesure de
contrôle de la contamination de la
contamination
avec ses défauts et avec sept nouveaux
variants nous avons plus de cas alors
pour bien qu'on comprenne on nous disait
déjà que le premier entre guillemets
virus était extrêmement contagieux là on
nous dit que c'est jusqu'à plus de 2 50%
voire plus contagieux encore ça veut
dire quoi concrètement baraka n'y a que
le virus reste suspendue dans l'air qui
les voilà sur chaque table qu'il a du
mal finalement à partir des surfaces
qu'on comprenne bien ri gun
c'est une excellente question tout
d'abord ce que cela signifie et qu'il y
a plus de virus et comme il ya plus de
virus en circulation autour d'une
personne infectieuses alors il ya plus
de chances d'être contaminés et
effectivement ils restent plus longtemps
un temps les airs donc il y a plus
d'aérosols et effectivement il est plus
présent partout la plus dans les airs il
n'a plus sur les surfaces il y en a plus
en général c'est très vrai on attend
beaucoup évidemment des études
britanniques sur le recul qu'on a de ce
variant vous êtes les champions du
séquençage notamment
sur le côté pathogènes on nous dit
jusqu'à présent qu'il n'est pas plus
dangereux
ce variant est ce que vous me confirmer
encore à ce jour que c'est bien le cas
so good oui tout à fait la bonne
nouvelle c'est que ce virus n'est pas
plus virulente
malheureusement il n'est pas non plus
moins virulent et je souhaite rajouter
une autre bonne nouvelle c'est que je
suis extrêmement certain que le vaccin
fonctionne sur l'ancien variant comme le
nouveau variant car ce vaccin reconnaît
la protéine de spicules temps son
ensemble et non pas certains petits
éléments qui auraient pu être modifié
avec cette mutation on est content
d'entendre des bonnes nouvelles on va
pas on va pas se mentir battement kenya
une autre éventuelle bonne nouvelle je
sais pas si vous allez nous l'a confirmé
l'épidémiologiste britannique neil
ferguson inquiète un petit peu fait
parler de lui
voilà un petit peu sulfureux mais mais
bref un c'est quand même un professeur
de lyme perial college nous annoncer
aujourd'hui qu'il pense que l'on
pourrait déjà avoir atteint l'immunité
de groupe et l'épidémie se terminera en
notant laisse que vous partagez cet avis
optimiste de ce professeur de l'impérial
collège un autre show landaise
je ne suis pas certain que londres est
atteint l'immunité de groupe
il faut un taux d'immunisation de plus
de 60 à 70% et à partir de ce moment
seulement peut-on parler d'une unité
collective
je ne pense pas que nous nous soyons
déjà à ce niveau
cependant avec l'immunisation et le
nombre élevé de contamination dans le
pays
on peut espérer que d'ici au début de
l'automne
60 à 70% de la population aura été émise
suite à une contamination ou suite à une
vaccination
merci baratin par cani un expert en
maladies infectieuses à l'université
d'exeter en direct du royaume uni pour
vu de l'extérieur ce soir merci à vous
la pandémie de kobe 19 qui continue de
se propager en europe violemment touchés
par la dernière vague de contamination
le portugal pourrait se reconfigure
l'instar d'autres pays européens
les hôpitaux de la région de lisbonne
sont au bord de la rupture le président
portugais a lui aussi été testé au
positif positives puis négatif les
précisions de quentin mauclair devant
l'afflux de patients touchés par le
gault vide
le personnel hospitalier tente de
rassurer du calme tout va bien se passer
ok c'est pour cela que vous êtes ici
pour vous soigner d'accord allez du
calme après les fêtes de fin d'année
pendant lesquelles les restrictions
avaient été assouplies
le portugal s'est vu submergé par une
nouvelle vague de contamination ce lundi
le pays a recensé 122 morts en 24 heures
un record depuis le début de l'épidémie
à ce jour près de 4000 personnes sont
hospitalisées parmi lesquels 567 sont en
soins intensifs
résultat les hôpitaux de la région de
lisbonne sont au bord de la saturation
nous vivons une grosse pression avec
l'arrivée en masse de personnes
suspectées d'être infectées mais surtout
de patients déjà touché qui ont eu des
symptômes cliniques et qui doivent venir
aux urgences
ils ont besoin d'être observé de faire
des examens
on a une forte hausse des
hospitalisations dans les unités
qu'ovide mais aussi pour les cas les
plus graves dans les unités de soins
intensifs
ce lundi le président du portugal
marcelo rebelo de sousa a été testé
positif au sein skov 2 une fausse alerte
pour le chef d'état âgé de 72 ans
puisque deux autres tests sont venus
contredire le premier le test effectué
ce mardi matin par l'institut ricardo
georges et est revenu pour donner un
résultat négatif
le président de la république attend
désormais les instructions des autorités
sanitaires le week-end dernier le
président portugais estimait qu'il n'y
avait pas d'alternative au confinement
général après avoir consulté des experts
l'exécutif doit réunir un conseil des
ministres ce mercredi un nouveau
confinement similaire à celui de mars
pourrait voir le jour dès le lendemain
les commerces sont essentiels devraient
alors baisser de rideau comme les cafés
et restaurants et direction présent la
tunisie où les signaux sont au rouge là
bas aussi le taux de mortalité est l'un
des plus élevés dans la région s'alarme
l'om est sans espoir cependant le vaccin
celui de fraser by one tech prévue début
mars mais peut-être aussi ce pouvait on
retrouve notre reporter ben hassen
chébili à tunis pour plus d'explications
bonsoir bassem alors nous on est l es
tunisie au niveau de ce vaccin
l'écouté stéphanie la tunisie est
vraiment la traîne concernant le pack
sang ce vaccin qui pourrait protéger le
peuple tunisien cette pandémie de
colonna virus qui touche la population
depuis été mois et des mois depuis le
début de cette pandémie internationale
il ya eu plusieurs restes des phases de
confinement des phases de couvrot
mais la population tunisienne a du mal à
quand on observe çà dans les rues tout
au long des journées qu'on a pu passer à
l'extérieur ils ont du mal à respecter
certains codes notamment les codes
barrière de port du masque n'est pas
systématique de partout la raison pour
laquelle le gouvernement souhaite
vraiment acquérir un vaccin le plus
rapidement possible le président de la
république à monsieur wright avait déjà
demandé à son ministre des affaires
étrangères de multiplier les
correspondances des négociations et des
pourparlers avec les pays des pays des
étrangers qui sont quittés kipopo qui
possèdent ce vaccin qui pourrait
permettre à la tunisie de se réduire et
puis il y a eu comme vous l'avez dit cet
accord qui devait être signé avec le
groupe kaiser biotech pour avoir 2002
millions par an de doses pour la tunisie
mais c'est une commande qui traînent
arrivée qui doivent être prévus pour le
mois de mars est la raison pour laquelle
le chef de l'état a demandé à son mise
après l'étrange de multiplier les
correspondances avec d'autres pays qui
pourraient fournir ce vaccin là ce
vaccin tant attendu en tunisie la raison
pour laquelle la jeune fille s'est
tourné vers la russie
avec l'acquisition possible dans les
mois à venir du vaccin aux pique nique
v aujourd'hui ici à tunis les ministres
de la santé va aussi mais d'y aller
rencontrer l'ambassadeur de russie ici
en tunisie sergei ni colloque pour
discuter d'une vente d'une éventuelle
acquisition de ce vaccin
si la tunisie acquérir le vaccin le
russe sera le deuxième pays d'afrique
acquérir ce vaccin l'algérie qu'est
devenu il ya quelques jours le premier
pays d'afrique à acquérir ce vaccin qui
devrait être livré dans les semaines à
venir l'algérie pays voisins de la
tunisie qui compte vacciner avec ce pack
sans risque de 80 % de sa population
avec ça vous le disiez qu'il est très
attendu en tunisie parce qu'on assiste
clairement un rebond du coc vide dans le
pays bas sem
effectivement cette année tous les
voyants sont au rouge en tunisie que ce
soit de la part du ministère de la santé
qui essaye de communiquer tous les jours
face à la situation qui devient de plus
en plus incontrôlable si en tunisie et
le msm
m'en tirer la sonnette d'alarmé sur ce
petit pays qui manquent de tous les
[ __ ] l'iran d'animation ils sont
occupés à 100% donc la tunisie n'est
plus capable de pouvoir gérer cette
crise rend compte pas moins de 5000 284
morts depuis le début de cette pandémie
sans consent des lits en réanimation
occupée près de 160 mille cas a confirmé
par rapport aux 700 mille tests qui ont
été faits déjà de pilot mois brillé à
dernier donc des tests qui ne sont pas
généralisés en tunisie il faut savoir
que les tests pcr ici est payant donc au
vu de la situation catastrophique et
économiques en tunisie qui a été
notamment renforcée par la crise de
poche du coronavirus la population
tunisienne ne peut pas se permettre
d'aller se faire tester du le prix donné
rue du test pcr confinement pourrait
avoir lieu à partir de jeudi prochain
pour une durée de quatre à cinq jours
à 5 jours le gouvernement doré entend
apporter quelques précisions face à ce
qu'on vous raconte filmant mais le
gouvernement semble être désarmé n'a pas
d'autre choix que de remettre le pays en
confinement pour quelques jours afin de
se prémunir et surtout d'essayer de
limiter cette propagation
il a décidé de le faire à partir du 14
janvier prochain probablement puisque 14
janvier comme vous le savez marquera les
10 ans de la révolution de 2011 dans
l'évolution et qui a marqué le début du
printemps arabe et le gouvernement a
peur de rassemblements massifs à travers
tout le territoire des rassemblements de
population qui pourrait notamment
favorisé la le virus virus du corps la
danse à travers tout le pays les
syndicats également énormément syndicats
appellent à ce possible continent à
travers tout le pays
mais le gouvernement est clair même si
on arrivait à avoir ce vaccin dans les
mois à venir ça ne suffira pas
malheureusement à pouvoir limité
ralentir cette pandémie de coronavirus
ici en tunisie
merci bassem shérif sheriff en direct de
tunis pour toutes ces précisions
la stratégie vaccinale en palestine
cette fois les autorités ont annoncé
avoir signé quatre contrats d'achat de
vaccins contre le coc vide parmi le
vaccin en russe pour tomber dont on
parlait à l'instant la palestine devient
ainsi le premier pays du moyen-orient
autorisé l'utilisation de ce vaccin
selon le fonds russe d'investissements
directs la palestine devrait disposer de
tous ces lots de vaccins au plus tard
courant avril
c'est le premier pays du moyen-orient
ayant d'ores et déjà enregistré le
vaccin spoutnik v autorisée
officiellement pour un usage d'urgence
nous échangeons avec nos collègues
depuis décembre 2020 et nous avions à
l'époque sollicité presque 4 millions de
doses par la voie officielle de
l'ambassade
nous avons demandé à documentation
concernant le vaccin qui a été
officiellement envoyée au ministère
palestinien de la santé
elle a été examinée par nos collègues au
sein du ministère de la santé pour
évaluer l'efficacité et l'utilité du
vaccin ce bouclier ainsi que pour
identifier les effets indésirables les
études ont montré que son efficacité
était très élevé elle était d'environ 92
%
en même temps les effets secondaires
étaient négligeables aucun effet grave
n'a été signalé aux états unis première
sortie publique de donald trump depuis
les événements du capitole avec un
déplacement ce soir au texas pour
inspecter l'avancement des travaux de
son mur ont pris migrants l'occasion
pour le président américain sortant
banni des réseaux sociaux
nous ne voulons pas de violence jamais
de violence nous ne voulons absolument
pas de violence et en ce qui concerne la
destitution c'est vraiment la
continuation de la plus grande chasse
aux sorcières de l'histoire de la
politique c'est ridicule c'est
absolument ridicule
cette mise en accusation provoque une
colère énorme et vous le faites
et c'est vraiment une chose terrible qui
nous feront l'état d'urgence décrété à
washington en cause la crainte de
prochaines mobilisations preuve jusqu'à
15 dans la capitale cette nuit place au
vote sur la résolution déposée par les
démocrates président d'enclencher le 25e
amendement pour déclarer le président
sortant inapte à gouverner
le texte de mise en accusation rédigé
par les élus démocrates pour tenté de
destituer donald trump est déjà prêt ils
devraient être envoyées cette semaine au
sénat après le vote de la chambre des
représentants le but écarter
définitivement donald trump du pouvoir
il peut seulement accorder son propre
pardon pour des délits fédéraux
ils ne peuvent pas si innocente et pour
des délits détail c'est pourquoi il est
mise en examen dans l'état de new york
et c'est l'une des motivations que les
gens ont pour préconiser un impeachment
et bien j'aime le 25e amendement parce
que ça nous débarrasse de lui il n'est
plus en fonction mais il ya un fort
soutien au congrès pour mettre en
accusation le président une seconde fois
le texte reproche à l'actuel président
des états unis d'avoir mis en danger la
sécurité du pays lors de l'assaut du
capitole le 6 janvier dernier une
procédure de destitution qui vise aussi
à juger donald trump
même après la fin de son mandat dans le
but qu'ils ne puissent plus être
candidat à une élection présidentielle
une manoeuvre qui a donc lieu quelques
jours avant la cérémonie d'investiture
de joe biden
qui serait selon certains documents du
fbi a menacé par de nombreuses
manifestations dans le pays
une situation qui n'inquiète pas le
président élu
je n'ai pas peur de prêter serment en
plein air et je me fais briefé je pense
qu'il est essentiel de veiller très
sérieusement à ce que les personnes qui
se sont livrées à l'insurrection et qui
ont menacé la vie de personnes qui ont
souillé la propriété publique qui ont
causé de grands dégâts soient tenus pour
responsables et l'inquiétude gagne du
terrain aussi dans le camp du président
républicain
hier le ministre par intérim de la
sécurité intérieure à a présenté sa
démission
une cérémonie d'investiture qui devrait
donc se dérouler dans un contexte
particulièrement tendu
le pentagone a autorisé le déploiement
de quinze mille soldats de la garde
nationale à washington donald trump a
déjà confirmé son absence lors de la
cérémonie d'investiture une bonne chose
a estimé joe biden 25e avant cet outil
qui permettrait donc d'écarter un
président en exercice
s'il est jugé inapte les détails avec
quentin au clair battu par le démocrate
joe biden le 3 novembre lors de la
présidentielle
donald trump doit quitter la maison
blanche le 20 janvier
mais après des violences au capitole du
6 janvier l'actuel chef d'état est sous
la menace d'une procédure d' impeachment
en raison notamment du 25e amendement de
la constitution américaine adoptée en
février 1967
cet amendement permet de démettre à
président de ses fonctions en le
déclarant inapte c'est ensuite le vice
président qui prend sa place à la tête
du pays le vice-président et une
majorité de son cabinet peuvent demander
l'application du 25e amendement par une
déclaration écrite qui sera ensuite
transmise au président du sénat et de la
chambre des représentants le président
lui-même peut aussi invoquer cet
amendement s'il ne se sent plus en
mesure d'assurer ses fonctions pour une
durée déterminée
jamais le 25e amendement n'a été
utilisée dans l'histoire des états unis
la destitution de donald trump serait
donc inédite
outre son départ de la maison blanche
donald trump pourrait dire adieu à sa
carrière politique
si la procédure allait à son terme son
rêve de réélection en 2024 deviendrait
impossible
l'inpi schwint rendant à président
inéligible à vie et pour parler des
états unis nous sommes avec un paul
jorion sociologue auteur de la chute de
la météorite trump aux éditions du
croquant à paraître en janvier 2021
bonsoir paul journée on merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france donald trump
donc qu'il reste droit dans ses bottes
il estime que son discours de la semaine
dernière devant ses partisans avant
l'assaut du capitole était tout à fait
convenable peut-on le croire à ce que ya
du vrai dans cette déclaration selon
vous son point de vue l'ouïe bien
entendu c'est exactement ce qu'on
voulait il est dit-il le peuple est en
colère le peuple est en colère parce que
il ya une procédure d le pitch me tend
vers moi c'est la même chose c'est
toujours là là lâche la chasse aux
sorcières je suis la victime de la même
chasse aux sorcières qui a débuté il ya
cinq ans et il s'agit là il a fait demi
tour une fois de plus maintenant îlots
il se présentant en victime et eux ils
se la manière dont il agit aujourd'hui
en allant sur la muraille qui devrait
séparer donc les états unis du mexique
en faisant une étape à alamo ou le
fameux ford à la mouche ou les ou de
braves américains des zi cordier
dentiste texans se sont battus jusqu'au
dernier contre des mexicains
si ça passe à gauche et là quelques pas
non monsieur trump n'a pas l'intention
de monsieur tron pas l'intention que le
21 janvier il soit toujours président
des états unis et il agit à nouveau de
dans cette logique alors vous parlez de
chasse aux sorcières alors il est vrai
que désormais le président sortant est
honni 1
bâillonnée d'ailleurs même par les
réseaux sociaux qui l'ont banni pour
certains définitivement
est ce que c'est la bonne stratégie pour
les opposants à donald trump qu'on les
aime ou on n'aime pas mais est ce que
c'est le meilleur moyen finalement de le
faire taire que de vouloir absolument
le bayonnais oui absolument absolument
parce que bon on peut un peu critique et
bien entendu le type de démocratie qu'on
a aux états unis c'est un pays qui a
commandé un bilan extrêmement mitigés
par rapport à sa conduite envers
d'autres peuples
mais les américains sont voilà sont
convaincus que c'est leur type de l'upra
ci mérite qu'on la défende
or là maintenant monsieur monsieur trump
a déclaré la guerre à ce type de
démocratie et donc tous les moyens sont
bons effectivement pour essayer de
contrer ce qui est une honte connaît
dans l'histoire on a déjà vu des choses
comme ça c'est ce qu'on appelle un coup
d'état fasciste
tous les moyens sont bons pour une
population de résister à une tentative
de ce type là parce que comme je le
disais il ya un instant il n'a pas
l'intention de partir le vin le code
quand il dit à monsieur byden qui sera
pas là lors de l'inauguration il
faudrait le fort c'est d'être là c'est
un encouragement encore à ce qu'on
attaque que la fibre humaniste de deux
d'inauguration de monsieur byden site
rome n'est pas là si peu simplement
envoyé ses troupes pour essayer
d'empêcher d'empêcher que cette
passation de pouvoirs et lieu
aujourd'hui qu'elle serait finalement la
sortie la plus honorable pour donald
trump mais aussi pour la démocratie
américaine
une démission une destitution une
transition ordonnée comme la promise
donald trump
oui oui enfin il a promis sa non il faut
rayer ses amis c'est qu'il lui reste
amis lui disent qu'il faut dire qu'il
démissionne
c'est le cas de monsieur kelly qui a été
son chef de cabinet le général kelly qui
était son chef de cabinet pendant un
certain temps il parle plus à son à son
vice président monsieur me my penske il
a même demandé mercredi dernier à la
foule
content de son vice président non il ne
fera pas il ne démissionnera pas
on aurait espéré je dirais les partisans
ta démocratie l'américaine pour espérer
que là je dirai dans une dans une
approche en tenaille d'un côté la
destitution et de l'autre côté le 25e
amendement venant du côté de la
vice-présidence c'était en rien
peut-être de l'éliminer mais là on ne
sait pas ce qui ce qui est très
dangereux bien entendu c'est que ses
partisans appellent à une insurrection
généralisée le 17 dans quelques jours
non seulement au niveau de washington
mais au niveau des capitals de chacun
des états c'est-à-dire bronze qu'on
appellerait les préfectures en france de
la 50 endroits il y aurait eu une
tentative de ses partisans de rendre le
propre ajoute valérie mais de rendre le
pays à sa population qu'on annule le cph
aux élections selon eux qui ont eu lieu
bon le processus qui est en cours bien
entendu c'est la passation de monsieur
by dell ayant gagné de manière légitime
des élections dont il ya deux visions
absolument un inconciliables et elles
vont déboucher le manière la plus
probable
on aura quelque chose d'une sur deux
lors d'une insurrection généralisée ce
qu'on appelle en général d'une guerre
civile soit le 17 soit le bain merci et
bien nous serons ça évidemment avec
attention ici aussi sur arte france
merci à vous pas de gyan d'avoir été
avec nous en direct
restez avec nous donc quelques instants
noms viendront sur la stratégie
vaccinale française alors que le rythme
s'accélère ces derniers jours on les
vire on l'a défendu ardemment devant
l'assemblée et le sénat aujourd'hui
et puis nous parlerons de la détresse de
ces étudiants face à la crise sanitaire
détresse psychologique difficultés
financières décrochage les universités
tire la sonnette d'alarmé s'était
également en débat aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée nationale
[Musique]
la chasse est un lobby donc il pèse très
lourd il faut arrêter de dire que on a
besoin des chasseurs on a besoin de
régulation on n'a jamais eu la preuve de
ça cette réduction du débat justement
entre le tout blanc a le tout noir ne
nuit-elle pas finalement à l'idée même
que les français pour espère de la
chasse je crois pas que ça soit réduire
le débat de rappeler qu'au sien un
plaisir qui va jusqu'à la mort cc c'est
ça l'essentiel et c'est pour ça que
c'est un sujet très très épidermique
parce que si l'histoire de vie et de
mort
il faut protéger la végétation faut
protéger la faune il faut protéger notre
chanter tous asseyez n'oublions pas que
tous nos problèmes viennent du mépris
qu'on a sur le reste du monde vivant
donc il faut il faut arrêter de laisser
les chasseurs faire leur bêtise je suis
poli
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
le crime est tellement épouvantable que
je pense qu'une partie de l'église mais
comme une partie de la société ne veut
pas le voir de 1950 à aujourd'hui le
travail de la commission a permis
d'identifier trois mille victimes 1500
agresseurs ces chiffres sont forcément
très en deçà de la réalité puisque des
victimes sont décédées des victimes ne
peuvent pas parler peut-être ne
parleront jamais ça montre cette
tragédie qui lie à un système au tour
c'est-à-dire comment des agresseurs ont
ils pu agresser 10/20 parfois trente ans
nous sommes loin du bout du chemin à
vous savez des institutions se réforment
lentement l'église peut être encore plus
lentement je ne sais pas mais en tout
cas je pense que la prise de conscience
est fait de tels scandales de tels
drames de telles tragédies dans la vie
oblige à la vérité
[Musique]
21h soyez les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france pour cette deuxième des missions
tout de suite voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi
olivier verront auditionné aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée et au sénat défend bec et
ongles la stratégie vaccinale française
et le choix de la proximité seulement 1%
de varien d'origine anglaise pour le
moment parmi les pcr positif en france
ça pourrait s'accélérer ces prochaines
semaines la vaccination elle se poursuit
la ville de nancy devient la première à
faire vacciner les plus de 75 ans aurait
pas d' victimes de la crise du comider
également les jeunes sujets d'un débat à
l'assemblée aujourd'hui de notre droit
dans ses bottes il juge la procédure de
destitution totalement ridicule et son
discours d'avant l'assaut du capitole
tout à fait convenable le président en
déplacement aujourd'hui au texas pour
inspecter l'avancement des travaux de la
fameuse barrière anti migrants
l'opposition démocrate prévoit elle à un
vote sur une seconde procédure de
destitution joe biden sera lui investi
dans huit jours
[Musique]
les etats unis toujours il prélève dès
aujourd'hui des taxes supplémentaires
sur des produits européens bien concerné
pièces détachées d'avion vins français
cette mesure s'inscrit dans le cadre du
litige entre washington et bruxelles sur
les subventions accordées à
l'aéronautique est un volte face après
l'annoncé il ya une semaine de la
suspension jusqu'à nouvel ordre de ses
taxes à cuba à nouveau inscrit sur la
liste noire américaine des états
soutenant le terrorisme le ministre
cubain des affaires étrangères bruno
rodriguez énonce l'opportunisme
politique de l'administration preuve
lille avait été retirée de cette liste
en 2015 par barack obama lors de la
période de rapprochement historique
entre les deux pays
[Musique]
olivier vers enchaîne les auditions ce
mardi le ministre de la santé étaient
entendus sur la campagne de vaccination
après une première séance devant à la
commission des affaires sociales de
l'assemblée nationale
il s'est rendu dans la foulée au sénat
l'essentiel avec solène goda un peu plus
d'une heure pour répondre aux questions
des parlementaires
ce mardi le ministre de la santé a
défendu la stratégie vaccinale du
gouvernement dès les premières minutes
olivier vers en a donné le ton nous ne
naviguons pas à vue une stratégie a été
défini par la haute autorité de santé
qui est je le rappelle une autorité
indépendante et une logistique établis
avec des cabinets de conseil privé un
sujet sur lequel le ministre de la santé
était particulièrement attendue donc on
a on a de très solides entreprise
française qui fonctionne très bien
qu'ils sont capables de fournir tous les
services et ce serait ce pardon pour le
je mets des guillemets ce serait salle
parce que ce serait privé mais attendez
c'est pas du tout du tout du tout ma
vision de la france de l'esprit
d'entreprendre et de notre capacité de
nous appuyer sur toutes les compétences
réponse insatisfaisante pour le député
la france insoumises du nord adrien
quatre mains ce pourquoi l'état
s'affaiblit à ce point en recourant
systématiquement à des prestataires
privés pour des missions qui sont des
missions régaliennes de l'état
je pense notamment à au contrat passé
avec mc kinsey dont on nous dit qu'un
apporte deux millions d'euros par mois
n'at-on pas des logisticiens des gens
capables de planifier au sein de
l'appareil d'état bref il ya beaucoup de
questions autour de sa stratégie
vaccinale face à un démarrage de la
vaccination au compte-gouttes la
transparence des chiffres a elle aussi
été évoquée j'ai demandé à ce que tous
les jours à 19h30 au plus tard soit
publié les données dont nous disposons
c'est à dire le nombre de vaccins
réalisé par région le pourcentage de
population protégée
le nombre de doses dont disposent les
régions et ainsi le pourcentage de doses
qui ont été consommées dans chaque
région
l'accès aux vaccins notamment en milieu
rural était aussi au coeur de l'audition
olivier verrons a écarté la réquisition
des stades leur préférant une politique
de proximité n'est pas fait le choix de
ces gros vaccinodromes à l'échelle
régionale qui aurait impliqué pour des
personnes âgées de quatre
cinq ans en plein hiver de faire 150 km
et des heures de queue à l'extérieur
d'un gymnase je revendique que cela et
je crois que c'est très bien accepté par
les élus
enfin les députés ont mis sur la table
la question de la mobilisation des
personnalités publiques pour inciter les
français à se faire vacciner a urgence
olivier véran répond patience pour moi
l'exemplarité vu ce que j'ai à dire
c'est d'attendre son tour c'est
d'attendre son tour
je suis médecin soignant ministre de la
santé
je suis âgée de moins de 50 ans je ne
fais pas vacciner
olivier verrons qui a aussi rappelé
l'objectif du gouvernement
un million de personnes vaccinées à la
fin du mois de février
pour l'heure près de 140 mille personnes
ont été vaccinées depuis le début de la
campagne le 27 décembre dernier
c'est environ cinq fois moins que
l'allemagne ou l'italie
eux aussi fortement impacté par
l'épidémie la france était sur la bonne
voie pour faire face à cette deuxième
vague et cette troisième qui semble
poindre avec le vario onglet l'exécutif
utilise-t-il les bonnes armes pour en
parler nous retrouvons tout de suite
alexis pour lancer notre rubrique
l'édito
[Musique]
bonsoir alexis poulain merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france grosse journée on l'a
vu pour olivier vers en audition de mise
la santé à l'assemblée et au sénat grand
oral sur la stratégie sanitaire du
gouvernement olivier ferrand qui s'est
défendu de tout cafouillage non nous ne
naviguons pas à vue a martelé le
ministre de la santé
oui alors c'est une drôle de l'image
qu'il a utilisée parce que vu de loin on
a l'impression d'être en plein naufrage
sur un radeau un bateau ivre dans le
brouillard
alors on navigue pas vu mais on sait pas
si on n'est pas loin du cap de bonne
espérance ou pas loin des 40e rugissants
puisque tout est finalement la
transparence tant promise elle n'est pas
là elle arrive alors sur les doses
évidemment il a fallu beaucoup de
patience pour arriver à savoir enfin
combien de personnes sont vaccinées
mais malgré l'accélération de cette
campagne de vaccination
la france reste dernière durant avec 140
milles vacciner je crois c'est très peu
et le variant angles air de ce virus qui
est beaucoup plus contagieux qui est sur
le territoire déjà beaucoup et on a
l'impression qu'on nous ménage pour ne
pas dire plus tard qu'il va falloir
encore confiné chaque semaine c'est la
même chose c'est pas chaque jour c'est
la même chose mais c'est toujours à peu
près la même séquence conseil de défense
puis jean castex qui parle on va encore
avoir ça cette semaine on a l'impression
d'être enfermé dans le film un jour sans
fin
toutes les semaines c'est à peu près le
même cirque qui se répète avec les mêmes
cafouillage avec les mêmes scandale
aujourd'hui on l'a vu un devant les
députés les réponses de libérant et est
peu satisfaisante
oui il dit faire confiance aux
entreprises privées pour ce qui est de
la prise de rendez vous pour la
vaccination
ce n'était pas le cas rappelez-vous en
mars lorsque nombre d'entreprises
privées avaient appelé le gouvernement
pour commander des masques pour aller
plus vite lorsque les cliniques avaient
demandé à faire partie du dispositif là
il n'était pas question de travailler
avec le privé or maintenant voilà qu'on
donne deux millions d'euros par mois à
des cabinets de conseil comme mckinsey
voilà qu'on fait confiance aux
entreprises tant mieux pour celles qui
vont pouvoir organiser la logistique
mais ça veut dire quoi que l'état est
incapable que les responsables sont
irresponsables et qu'ils ne savent plus
quoi faire donc on navigue peut-être pas
vu mais alors j'aimerais savoir si on
est ou pas en plein naufrage et puis
c'est un discret qui viennent des
conseils de défense
on al impression qu emmanuel macron est
de plus en plus en colère qu'ils
poussent la haute autorité de la santé à
la faute en lui mettant la pression pour
que la vaccination arrivent plus vite
quitte à faire fi du consentement de la
consultation médicale donc ça avance au
niveau de la communication et encore
mais sur le plan vaccinal on ne sait
toujours pas où on en est et une
communication alexis resserré autour de
trois ministres précisément oui alors
seulement trois ministres vont être
autorisés à parler après les fameux
conseil de défense
outre jean castex le profil lisse on
aura olivier ferrand ministre de la
santé ça c'est normal gabriela talent le
porte parole et puis agnès pannier ou
nager à l'industrie qui vont nous
expliquer doctement quelles sont les
lignes de paroles qu'ils auront appris
sagement parce que on a vu dans le
cafouillage des ministres qui sortait
des chiffres du chapeau sur le nombre de
vaccins d'ici la fin du printemps sur le
nombre de doses sur le territoire donc
pour éviter tout ça voilà ce qu'ils vont
pouvoir parler et puis il ya quelqu'un
qui a totalement disparu du dispositif
sans doute n'avait-il pas les faveurs du
président c'est alain fischer le
monsieur vaccin qui était censé
coordonner cette campagne massive de
vaccination
on l'a très peu vu depuis qu'il a ce
rôle parfois on l'aperçoit un dimanche
on l'entend au détour d'une radio de
plateaux télé et puis il disparaît et là
il est totalement hors du dispositif on
a l'impression que c'est vraiment la
république en marche qui reprend la
communication et pourquoi parce que
c'est un enjeu de taille pour emmanuel
macron si cette campagne vaccinale est
un échec comme l'ont été les masses que
les tests comme toute la halle la
stratégie sanitaire est un échec
alors pour lui c'en est fini la
politique il ne pourra pas se
représenter en 2022 devant un bilan
aussi catastrophique donc aujourd'hui
deux choses rattraper l'allemagne ne pas
être le dernier élève faire tout pour
que les français aient confiance et
aller se faire vacciner en comptant sur
le nombre de français qui souhaitent se
faire vacciner avec cette nouvelle
technologie de la rn et éviter surtout
une pénurie parce que qu'est ce qui se
passe là encore le gouvernement fait
comme en mars et il ya un an
gère la pénurie n'y a pas assez de doses
donc même si les français avaient envie
de se faire vacciner en masse ils ne
pourraient pas parce qu'on a des
problèmes de logistique nous les
cabinets de conseil et des problèmes
d'approvisionnement
donc ça reste épineux ça reste dangereux
et ça devient politiquement explosif
alexis est un mot sur toutes les lèvres
évidemment que l'on craigne ou qu'on le
souhaite un troisième confinement est ce
que la france peut-elle en vivres à un
autre alors économiquement
psychologiquement un troisième
confinement et ce serait catastrophique
ce serait peut-être même
contre-productif et le début d'une
révolte contre cette folie sanitaire qui
rend les gens fous et qui met l'économie
à néant
on a des chiffres terribles qui viennent
d'études qui parle de 75% de restaurants
qui ne pourraient ne pas rouvrir le
monde de la culture le monde de la
restauration les stations de ski des
secteurs entiers qui sont à l'arrêt le
nombre de gens qui vont aussi se
retrouver sans emploi il y avait une
marche aux flambeaux ce soir à marseille
justement pour condamner les
destructions d'emplois et faire que si
on est capable de faire un plan
sanitaire alors il faut faire aussi un
plan d'urgence pour préserver les
emplois autant que faire ce peu c'est ce
qu'on essaye de faire bruno le maire
selon ses dires mais je me demande quel
comment il arrive à faire des
projections tels qu'ils nous les propose
6 % de croissance pour 2021 il parle là
d'un défi mais c'est même pas un défi là
on est dans la folie ou bien il prend
des substances je ne sais pas c'est
incroyable de penser qu'un chiffre
pareil ce serait impeccable même au
deuxième semestre
donc on est dans la foi on est dans le
discours qui n'a plus rien à voir avec
la réalité et c'est grave parce que en
attendant les dettes s'accumulent et
faillite s'accumulent et on veut pas pas
qu'on va pouvoir redémarrer l'économie
parce que cette campagne de vaccination
ne sera pas non plus l'espoir tant
attendue elle va prendre du temps et le
vaccin on attend d'avoir d'un retour
pour voir s'il sera suffisamment
efficace pour contrer la propagation de
cette épidémie
donc rien et nenê sur on reste
effectivement dans navigue à vue
mais une chose est sûre un troisième
confinement là ce serait extrêmement
délicat pour le gouvernement de gérer
cela et je crois que les mesures
sanitaires depuis le début ont montré
qu'elles étaient relativement peu
efficace que ce soit les masques que ce
soit les confinements il y avait les
gestes barrière
heureusement qu'on les a parce que on
parle de projection et non on aurait eu
peut-être les quatre cent mille morts
que d emmanuel macron mais on attend de
voir
qu'est-ce qui pourrait être efficace
alors est ce qu'il ne faut pas à ce
moment là un confinement total une
fermeture des frontières et le monde qui
s'arrête pendant un mois pour que ce
virus
arrête de voyager ça me paraît compliqué
personne évidemment ne souhaite une
issue pareil donc tous les espoirs
aujourd'hui repose sur la campagne de
vaccination et ses désespoirs bien léger
d'un troisième confinement clairement
c'est non merci alexis paulin est
justement eux en souffriraient également
moins malades du kobe mais frappé par
ses conséquences sociales éducatives ou
psychologique le lourd tribut payé par
les jeunes à cette crise sanitaire était
au centre du premier débat à l'assemblée
nationale 2021
aujourd'hui écouter le premier ministre
jean castex
il paie un lourd tribut à cette crise
sanitaire
je recevrai à nouveau ce vendredi
l'ensemble des représentants de la
communauté universitaire d'une part pour
dresser le bilan des mesures que nous
avons prises en fin d'année dernière et
pour étudier avec eux les voies et
moyens par tout cela sera nécessaire de
les conforter et de les amplifier
c'est à l'honneur de notre pays de ne
pas laisser tomber ses étudiants de
venir à leur rencontre et à leur aide
dans ces moments si particuliers
je vous mets les mesures de restrictions
sanitaires et ses conséquences sur la
santé mentale des étudiants cela
inquiète les présidents d'université une
détresse qui tuera davantage à long
terme selon le doyen strasbourg
illustration à lyon le week-end dernier
où un étudiant s'est défenestré dans sa
résidence universitaire pour ses proches
la cause de son geste et fait désespérer
ses biens sont musulmans liés à la crise
sanitaire luis carballo avec cyrielle
benavides bill polian c'est dans la
résidence universitaire juste eu à
villeurbanne qu'un jeune homme a sauté
d'une fenêtre du cinquième étage ce
vendredi soir actuellement hospitalisé
avec un pronostic vital engagé
personne n'a pu anticiper l'acte de d
reste de cet étudiant en première année
de master de droit à l'université lyon
iii si la faculté avait été ouverte
si il allait voir ses camarades
peut-être qu'un d'entre eux auraient pu
se dire mais tu vas pas bien aujourd'hui
tu as l'air patrac tu veux en parler
viens on va on va en parler ensemble on
va on aurait sans doute pu le détecter
ou même ses professeurs les raisons de
ce geste ne sont donc pas déterminé pour
le moment mais nombre d'élèves et de
professeurs ont ce même sentiment
romain narbonne et lui a été l'un des
premiers à trouver son camarade sur le
sol sous le choc
il a posté sur facebook un cri de
détresse face à l' isolement des jeunes
d'autant plus palpable
en cette période de crise sanitaire
résultat en l'espace de quelques heures
des centaines de commentaires
d'étudiants dont certains qui pensent
qu'à passer à l'acte d'après ce jeune
homme de 19 ans le colis de 19,6 y est
pour quelque chose
le coroner virus est temps est un
facteur très aggravant il met des
multiplications sur les faiblesses des
étudiants nous n'avons plus nos petits
boulots nos jamais notre job étudiant
n'existe quasiment plus pour ma part moi
qui étais serveurs j'ai subi un
licenciement économique
ensuite nous sommes tous isolés
c'est quelque chose qui qui est tout
nouveau qu'il vient d'arriver
mais c'est quelque chose qui devient
terrible eric carpano le président de
l'université lyon iii a indiqué qu'une
cellule d'écouté psychologique avait été
mise en place ce lundi
ainsi qu'un numéro vert pour accompagner
les étudiants et tous ceux qui en
auraient besoin est les conséquences
psychologiques mais aussi économique de
la crise sanitaire chez les étudiants on
en parle maintenant avec nos invités
place à notre décryptage
et pour en parler
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
jacques guillaume administratrice de
l'association gaelis élu au conseil
d'administration de l'université lyon
iii bonsoir à vous au jeune guillaume à
vos côtés jacques smith délégué national
de l'uni l'union nationale inter
universitaire merci à vous aussi d'être
avec nous alors après la tentative de
suicide d'un étudiant lyonnais la
semaine dernière votre association jade
guillaume tire la sonnette d'alarmé il
faut faire de la santé mentale des
étudiants une urgence nationale vous
vous êtes donc à lyon 3 quelle est la
situation sur le campus
qu'est ce que vous observez alors la
situation assez complexe guichet de
l'absence totale de vie au sein de
l'université c'est à dire que pour
l'instant on n'a encore que des courants
distant ciel donc on n'a pas de pour
l'instant il ne se passe pas grand chose
si ce n'est beaucoup d'action sur les
réseaux sociaux beaucoup d'action
virtuelle des volonté de mettre en place
des manifestations on a essayé de
réfréner aussi par respect pour
l'étudiant en question l'idée aussi
c'est de tirer la sonnette d alarme et
de dire que voilà il faut il faut agir
et éventuellement prendre conscience de
l'urgence à laquelle les étudiants qu'on
fasse alors c'est vrai que la crise
sanitaire fait évidemment beaucoup de
mal aux étudiants en temps on parle
parfois d'ailleurs - parce qu'ils sont
un malade analyse justement du président
de l'université de lyon iii eric carpano
capannori côté la fermeture des
universités les cours à distance l'arrêt
des activités sportives culturelles et
festives ont favorisé l'isolément et la
détresse psychologique
un drame humain se joue que nous ne
devons pas occulter ceci nous
questionnent sur notre rôle et notre
responsabilité collective
nous devons réagir un drame humain se
joue parfois que l'on sous-estiment la
situation vous inquiète également
jacques smit juan smith
c'est une catastrophe c'est clairement
une catastrophe
cela fait maintenant dix mois que la
crise sanitaire va a débuté depuis mars
dernier on a essayé d'alerter pour le
coup toutes les organisations étudiantes
représentatives ont essayé d'alerter les
le ministère le gouvernement pour
premièrement préparer la rentrée de
septembre dernier et puis ensuite pour
préparer cette rentrée si sur le second
semestre donc de janvier 2021 pour en
reparler rien n'a été fait clairement
les étudiants sont victimes de l'inertie
du gouvernement clairement depuis dix
mois on a l'impression d'être clairement
est véritablement la dernière roue du
carrosse ça joue sur trois choses
principales et peut-être qu'on pouvoir
en reparler pendant ce décryptage mais
clairement sur la qualité de la
formation on est dans l'enseignement
supérieur français pour une raison on
s'est battu pour et donc on veut la
qualité de la formation derrière il y à
la crise sociale est donc là clairement
on est complètement de mort avec la
catastrophe qui a pu se dérouler ce week
end
et puis troisièmement il ya aussi le
manque d'avenir
le manque de 2,2 de wii 2 d'avenir pour
les étudiants qui se disent il ya déjà
est ce que je vais pouvoir passer mon
année ce que je vais pouvoir passer mon
diplôme et est ce que je vais pouvoir
trouver un job et ça clairement c'est
quelque chose qui joue sur la détresse
psychologique des étudiants ils votent
pour terminer quand on entend la
conférence de presse de jean castex que
vous êtes étudiant et que vous entendez
jean castex le 7 janvier dernier donc
c'est à dire il ya quelques jours la
semaine dernière
qui n'a pas un seul mot 1 seulement pour
la vie estudiantine et pour les
étudiants de français pour la jeunesse
française
vous dites que c'est quand même un
immense problème
et quand vous l'entendez ce mardi à midi
répondre que cette semaine c'est une
priorité
on peut se demander où est le bon sens
et c'est pourquoi la priorité ne pouvait
pas être ne pouvait pas être dès la
semaine dernière rien effectivement eu
cette tentative de suicide peut-être que
ça fait réagir le gouvernement rappelle
à l'assemblée
aujourd'hui
guillaume mieux vaut tard que jamais on
l'espère pour vous qu'est ce que vous
attendez de la part du gouvernement
jacques smith nous dit on se sent
abandonnés mais concrètement qu'est ce
que les autorités pourraient faire pour
vous pour que ça aille mieux
alors il s'agirait d'abord de pouvoir
permettre aux universités d'étendre leur
leurs centres de santé on dit que il
faudrait à peu près un psychologue pour
1500 étudiants aujourd'hui on est rendu
compte et on a conscience que tout c'est
tout cet accompagnement sanitaire
nécessite des fonds et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui ces fonds sont absolument
indispensables qu'on a besoin
d'accompagnement donc sanitaire santé
mais aussi numérique et je pense pas
simplement aux étudiants mais aussi aux
enseignants qui n'ont pas l'habitude de
danser naevia numérique et ce qui peut
aussi conduire à une forme de
détérioration des liens entre l'étudiant
et son enseignant également de
détérioration de la formation elle-même
puisque finalement un enseignant qui n'a
jamais donné de cours ni par web ex ni
par zoom se retrouve dans une grande
incapacité
alors si le fait le choix de s'adapter
et qu'il a une formation à ce moment là
ça peut se passer ça peut bien se passer
mais sinon on est dans une grande dans
un as dans une forme d'attentisme entre
ses professeurs qui n'arrivent plus à
renseigner et ses étudiants qui ne
parviennent plus à apprendre et je crois
qu'il faut un accompagnement de des
autorités sur cette nouvelle formation
qui est maintenant virtuel se distend
ciel et qu'il faut pas attendre que les
drames comme celui ci se produisent
avant de réagir
alors justement mélange des étudiants
ont publié une tribune celle des
derniers des confiné c'est une lettre
ouverte à emmanuel macron dans laquelle
il dénonce ce dont vous parlez un
l'accès des étudiants aux cours en
présentiel regarder en limitant l'accès
des étudiants en cours en présentiel
c'est toute une génération que vous
sacrifiez et l'avenir du pays que vous
mettez en danger
jacques smith sont vraiment ces courants
destans ciel qui cristallise
le mal être des étudiants vous savez
quand vous passez tout votre semaine de
lundi matin 8 heures au samedi soir 20h
en visio derrière un écran d'ordinateur
je crois pas qu'on puisse parler d'une
vie étudiante correct et est pour le
moins épanouissante
un étudiant jeune n'est pas fait pour
rester cloîtré dans un oeuf est carré un
jeune de 20 ans n'est pas fait pour cela
vous quand vous regardez des chiffres
alors c'est toujours intéressant avec
les limites que l'on connaît aux
chiffres et aux enquêtes
mais quand vous voyez que près de 23% et
est donc un cinquième des étudiants
qu'on lui des pensées suicidaires
je crois ne pas m'avancer trop fort et
trop loin en disant qu'il ne fallait pas
clairement attendre ce week-end et la
catastrophe s'est souvenu pour
effectivement comprendre que le distant
ciel et que le manque de vie sociale et
que le manque de proximité de
camaraderie et de la vie étudiante tout
simplement peuvent amener à une détresse
psychologique
il lance donc aujourd'hui ce qu'on
demande au ministère c'est déjà de tout
simplement d'aider les établissements
est de réunir des universités alors bien
évidemment avec les conditions
sanitaires et dans le respect de deux de
ses de ses gestes barrières de la
distanciation sociale mais en tout cas
quand on nous dit qu'avant noël et il y
avait eu toute une communication du
gouvernement
en dix ans nous avons discuté avec tous
les présidents d'université avec la cpu
pour pouvoir dès le lundi 4 janvier
commençait à réouvrir en présentiel ou
nous a parlé de groupes de 10 personnes
on nous a parlé le groupe de dd en 2011
eh bien ça fait une semaine et demie du
coup maintenant tu es tu on se rend bien
compte que c'est un échec que c'est un
échec et que quand madame vidal nous
parle d'un possible d'une possible de
l'ouverture et bars retour à la normale
début février
on se dit qu'on est bien loin de cet
objectif et donc on leur demande tout
simplement de 2 d'avancé sur sur ce
projet là oui on précisant qu'un rapport
parlementaire mi décembre avait déjà mis
en lumière qu'un jeune sur six eux
auraient arrêté ses études depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire ça fait
beaucoup quand on vous écoute on
s'inquiète un peu parce que c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde parle d'un
éventuel
troisième confinement est ce que ça va
être vivable sur vivable si j'ose dire
même si c'est pas français
pour vous le traîniez on imagine
énormément ce seront confinement
français si je peux me permettre je
voudrais donner simplement l'exemple des
étudiants lycéens qui ont passé de
l'année dernière donc le coc vide dans
leur année avec le co vide ils n'ont pas
passé le bac ils ont passé la plupart de
leurs années en distance yale et leur
première année donc de licence 1 pour
ceux qui sont à l'université a été
également en distance yale donc depuis
deux ans ils n'ont vécu aucun examen
si ce n'est des examens en présentiel
pour certaines facultés et encore et ils
n'ont jamais eu la chance de s'intégrer
alors repoussé faire encore un
confinement où on élargir s7 cette
fracture laquelle fracture numérique est
une fracture sociale mais aussi une
traque tueur psychologique et une
inquiétude aussi pour se dire ok donc là
je ne sais pas où je suis je sais pas
trop ce que ce que je dois faire mais je
sais pas non plus où je vais et je crois
que l'étudiant ce qu'il a besoin c'est
d'un but il a besoin de se dire là je je
vais passer mon diplôme je vais la voir
je vais pouvoir passer l'année suivante
retrouver mes amis m'inscrire dans des
associations et tout ça ça n'existe plus
mais à quoi ils sont proches merci à
vous en tout cas à tous les deux bon
courage en tout cas j'adore guillaume
jacques smith en espérant pour vous
d'avoir des bonnes nouvelles évidemment
merci d'avoir été en direct sur rt
france dans quelques instants rester
avec nous reviendrons sur l'opposition
démocrate qui tend de destituer donald
trump à huit jours de la fin de son
mandat lui reste sur sa ligne
le président américain qui juge la
procédure ridicule et son discours
d'avant l'assaut du capitole tout à fait
convenable à l'instant il lance un appel
à la paix et au calme aux états unis il
juge aussi qu'il n'y a aucun risque
qu'il soit démis en vertu du 25e
amendement est toujours aux etats-unis
nous évoquons ces taxes supplémentaires
sur des produits européens comme le vin
français au grand dam évidemment de la
filière viticole
[Musique]
ce qu'on attend un peu de vous c'est les
idées pour en sortir est votre jugement
notamment de la façon dont cette crise
est gérée ce qui a été montré au cours
de la gestion de cette crise c'est le
déficit d'anticipation pour moi la
politique c'est d'abord d'être efficace
des gains manque de cohérence
il ya il ya un manque de fiabilité il ya
un manque de confiance faut vite
retrouver la confiance vous considérer
aujourd'hui que que la france a été plus
mauvaise que beaucoup de nos payes et
étrangers vous sommes le pays qui a
inventé les vaccins avec pasteur dont la
réactivité française n'a pas été à la
hauteur de notre réputation tout le
monde a vu que dès le mois de juillet
les chinois vacciner pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a attendu si longtemps
la question est de savoir mais comment
est-ce qu'on va retrouver un équilibre
en faisant en sorte que les épreuves que
nous subissons actuellement deviennent
des forces et non pas des handicaps
durable
[Musique]
on parle de l'afrique comme d'un
continent en perpétuelle de vie son
dysfonctionnement actuel tient à
l'absence de redistribution à la
population par des dirigeants qui ont
une fâcheuse tendance à tout garder pour
les pays occidentaux ont favorisé cette
dérive en encourageant le maintien au
pouvoir de politiciens de plus en plus
âgés pour assurer la stabilité des pays
et des sourires
elles ont eu la prétention de croire que
les valeurs qu'elle défend des est
imposé par la force dans leur conquête
était universel dans cette terre des
possibles où s'esquissent les figures du
monde à venir
il faut changer notre logiciel et
arrêtez de dénigrer le faire à
l'africaine en octroyant co management à
l'anglo-saxonne
[Musique]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française
c'était après les attentats du 11
septembre et quand on vient vous voir et
qu'on vous dit ben écoutez vous avez de
la première femme qui allait rentrer
dans ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu qu' ben voilà c'est fini pour
moi est ce que je sors mon arme
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du majeur mais
quel est le rapport avec la radiation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
[Musique]
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france si vous nous rejoignez aux
états unis déplacement ce soir de
donnant repos texas pour inspecter
d'avancement des travaux de son mur anti
migrants
l'occasion pour le président américain
sortant banni des réseaux sociaux de
s'exprimer face aux caméras de
télévision c'est en ce moment en vous le
voyez en grec
sur ces images donald trump qui vient
d'indiquer que selon lui il n'y avait
aucun risque qu'il soit démis en vertu
du 25e amendement
il a lancé un appel à la paix et au
calme
l'une de ses rares prises de parole
depuis les violences du capitole de
mercredi dernier vous le savez il avait
été banni des réseaux sociaux donc ils
s'expriment désormais devant les caméras
de télévision et s'est exprimé avant
aussi de prendre un hélicoptère tout à
l'heure je vous propose de l'écouter
nous ne voulons pas de violence jamais
de violence nous ne voulons absolument
pas de violence et en ce qui concerne la
destitution c'est vraiment la
continuation de la plus grande chasse
aux sorcières de l'histoire de la
politique c'est ridicule c'est
absolument ridicule
cette mise en accusation provoque une
colère énorme et vous le faites
et c'est vraiment une chose terrible qui
nous font jour du départ de donald trump
de la maison blanche à l'état d'urgence
est décrété à washington en cause des
craintes de nouvelles mobilisations
protruck même si ce dernier a appelé au
calme vous l'avez entendu jusqu'à quinze
mille soldats déployés dans la capitale
selon le pentagone cette nuit place au
vote sur la résolution déposée par les
démocrates demandant au vice président
mike pence d'enclencher le 25e
amendement pour déclarer le président
sortant inapte à gouverner pas de chance
que celle ci aboutisse on le répète
vient de déclaré donald trump
les vins français sous la menace d'une
nouvelle taxe américaine
axe trump entre en vigueur aujourd'hui
et va imposer de nouveaux droits de
douane aux bouteilles françaises
même sort pour les pièces détachées de
l'aéronautique
une taxe qui arrive après en revivant
revirement annoncé la semaine dernière
les vignerons français qui s'inquiètent
pour l'avenir
c'est vrai que les vins américains il
n'y a pas beaucoup qui sont importés en
france donc c'est vrai que j'en ai c'est
plus nous qui sommes à été puisque donc
en on a chaud on a on n'exporte pas mal
aux etats-unis en revanche les les
américains eux exporté très tôt chez
nous donc c'est vrai que même si nous
après ans par mesure de rétorsion
on augmente les taxes sur les vins
américains ça le problème vient plutôt
pour nous que pour sur ce sujet
l'analyste henri sterdyniak économiste à
l'observatoire français des conjonctures
économiques et non des économistes
atterrés
les etats unis ont obtenu le droit de
taxer à 7,5 milliards de produits
européens pour compenser les subventions
que l'europe fait à airbus
les etats unis ont estimé que jusqu'à
présent il n'avait pas atteint 17,5
milliards de produits taxés et donc ils
ont décidé de taxer en plus les pièces
détachées de l'aéronautique
les vins en vrac et le cognac l'armagnac
palais les alcools forts
la conséquence c'est de renforcer en
quelque sorte la position de boeing
par rapport à un bus sur le marché
américain et surtout d'introduire des
pénalités pour les viticulteurs
européens viticulteurs justement on en
parle avec un thomas montagne président
de la confédération européenne des
vigneron indépendant bonsoir thomas
montagne merci d'être avec nous alors
cette nouvelle taxe américaine sur le
vin et les pièces aéronautiques entre en
vigueur aujourd'hui concrètement qu'est
ce que ça change pour vous ouais ça
continue sur la lancée qui étaient déjà
très mauvaises âmes on a perdu le la
filière avicole franco-française je
parle déjà perdu 400 millions d'euros ce
chiffre d'affaires cette taxe et on va
probablement perdre un milliard sur un
2021 on est on est vraiment fatiguée
quoi d'être pris en otage quelque chose
qui ne pensait absolument pas puisque ça
concernant l'aéronautique cdk judiciaire
a fait voler entre boeing et airbus qui
sont pendants depuis dix ans au plus 15
ans ça nous tombe dessus
ils vont alors on est vraiment les
talents de la farce les cocus de la fère
et s'agacent prodigieusement sonne
coûter cher essentiellement à la france
parce que bon bien sûr les vins
allemands sont aussi sans sel touché
mais l'allemagne ou viticoles sait pas
grand chose je pense qu'il a exporté les
80 millions d'euros peut-être aux etats
unis c'est sillonnent par rapport à ce
qu'on fait nous donc ça ne touchera pas
voilà blanc a une fois de plus
l'administration très très très bonne je
pense pour diviser pour mieux régner
je crois qu'on paye aussi les efforts
notre gouvernement pour mettre en place
une taxe sur les gaffes à voilà j'ai
rien à dire là dessus mais c'est ce qui
se passe quand même somme voilà les
otages cause qui dépasse totalement
pour vous c'est véritablement une
sanction ou punitive envers la france en
tout cas ça se termine comme ça même si
ce n'est peut-être pas intentionnel de
la part de l'administration américaine
ou désinformation gc d'intentionnel je
me trompe peut-être mais je vous parlais
existantes et pour beaucoup
notre président a souvent des positions
assez assez dur en travers
l'administration train donc voilà il ya
des rétorsions je veux pas je parle j'ai
rien à dire at il simplement c'est vrai
voilà une fois de plus c'est la
structure française essentiellement en
europe qui se fait avoir et qui n'est
pas soutenu par le rendez vous le disais
ce n'est pas ce qu'on parle europe
pardonnez mon nom parce que on aurait pu
penser que depuis le député de départ
leur donnerait à la rencontre elle a mis
en place des rétorsions commerciales
elle y est autorisée par aussi puisqu'il
y avait un cas judiciaire airbus contre
le bruit d'un côté comme de l'autre les
taxis ont été mises en place nous on
appelle à la désescalade depuis
longtemps moi j'avais vu et qui ainsi
logan est l époque était commissaire au
commerce deux ou trois fois
en début d'année on a vu la commission à
bruxelles un peu avant le début du
confinement
ils nous ont répondu écoutez nous on
voit rien au chiffrement et pas de
problème la blague voilà je vous dis oui
la commission européenne et aux abonnés
absents sur ce sujet complètement à
quelle échelle cette taxe va affecter
les producteurs français dans un
contexte déjà très compliquée par le
quotidien qui on l'imaginé vous a fait
du mal également
oui la filière et en est un petit peu en
souffrance puisque tous les to les chr
cafés hôtels restaurants sont fermés
comme vous savez les soucis dans toute
l'europe
c'est ça représente grosso modo entre un
tiers et un quart du marché
donc même si à quelques rattrapage se
font ceux d'autres circuits
globalement la consommation de vin étant
est en diminution
il ya donc quelque part une
surproduction qui se met en place au
niveau européen dès qu'il ya un peu de
surproduction vacances est un marché qui
n'est pas élastique à des baisses de
prix considérables sur certains segments
donc je crois qu'effectivement nous
allons vers des temps assez c'est
compliqué pour la viticulture
alors les champagne et les vins mousseux
seraient exemptés de taxes pour quelles
raisons jean même pas les mots pour
autant que je sache les champagnes lui
je suppose que les producteurs
champenois dois dire un grand merci au
lobbying terrible de monsieur permament
auprès d'eux je suppose c'est pour ça
aussi probablement que le nez champagne
et lé cognac ne sont pas tous accès
cessera taxer uniquement pour les
bouteilles est supérieur à 23 dollars de
deux prix engone donc une partie des
cognacs et notamment les jeunes cognac
il soit beaucoup bu aux etats unis
échapperont probablement attendons c'est
oui alors justement c'est pas fini oui
excusez moi allez-y
je pense que non l'administration
américaine et des passions du tout que
ça change quand quand monsieur bailly
d'administration prendront la suite ça
on n'en sait rien mais assez probable
que ça même si ça change ça met du temps
à changer en tout cas il y aura toujours
cette histoire de taxes gaffard et rire
le trouve qu'on n'a pas je pense qu'ils
vont garder une poire pour la soif si je
puis dire est que le ils ont le rêve du
cognac il au champagne toujours ce goût
des ça pourrait changer ça serait
dramatique pour le champagne français
qui tu as forcément français le
champagne qui est déjà assez fortement
impacté sur ces marchés actuellement
effectivement c'était ma question est ce
que vous espérez un changement avec
l'administration maiden et si c'est pas
le cas comment riposter est ce qu'au
niveau européen au niveau français
puisque vous êtes et plus conserver
est-ce qu'il ya quand même l'espoir de
sortir de cette situation pour vous on
garde toujours espoir certainement bon
mais comme je vous disais c'est pas à
court terme je pense que monsieur miles
et sur l'administration va voir beaucoup
de choses à mettre en place et à régler
donc ils vont arriver
je ne suis pas sûr que bob layton lui
écrire que la personne responsable au
niveau aux etats unis l'administration
et s'occupe de ça son poste soit changé
lui ai pensé pas certain et fabrice de
mettre quelques mois donc je ne vois
rien de
rapide arrivée on est chanceux côté de
ce mois merci beaucoup thomas montagne
président de la confédération européenne
des vignerons indépendants d'avoir été
avec nous et l'administration 30 pendant
parle encore puisque elle replace cuba
sur la liste américaine des états
soutenant le terrorisme
l'annoncé a été faite par le chef de la
diplomatie américaine hier dans un
communiqué il reproche à cuba son
soutien répété selon lui à des actes de
terrorisme international la vanne de son
côté dénoncé l'opportunisme politique
écouter mecs m'ont p o et le ministre
des affaires étrangères que dans le
département d'état classe et cuba comme
état soutenant le terrorisme pour avoir
apporté son soutien de manière répétée à
des actes de terrorisme international en
donnant refuge à des terroristes
avec cette mesure nous allons à nouveau
tenir le gouvernement de cuba pour
responsable et envoyer un message clair
le régime castro doit mettre fin à son
soutien au terrorisme international et à
la subversion de la justice américaine
nous condamnons la qualification
hypocrite et cynique de cuba comme état
sponsor du terrorisme annoncées par les
états unis
l'opportunisme politique de cette action
est reconnue par tous ceux qui sont
sincèrement préoccupé par le fléau du
terrorisme et de ses victimes
écoutez c'est quelques réactions dans
les rues de cuba cuba être tout le monde
dans le domaine de la santé et dans
d'autres domaines pour le bien et non
pour le mal ce pays n'a jamais été un
pays terroriste
ce pays
ce qu'il a fait c'était des les gens
pour tous c'est aider les gens pour tous
cuba est un pays internationaliste c'est
à dire contre le terrorisme voilà ce que
je peux dire et cuba maintiendra
toujours sa position à partir de la
guerre d'indépendance et je pense que
nous les cubains en tant qu'héritier
patriotes dément biz maintiendrons notre
position d'être contre le terrorisme
étape 1 pour en parler nous sommes avec
maurice lemoine journalistes
spécialistes l'amérique latine bonsoir
maurice lemoine une première réaction à
cette décision d'administration en trump
à quoi joue donald trump selon vous à
une semaine de la fin de son mandat
politique de la terre brûlée
écoutez ma première réaction d'ailleurs
c'est de me dire que si actuellement
washington est quasiment en état de
siège avec 10000 à 15000 gardes
nationaux qui sont arrivés pour la 10e
fois c'est pas du et c'est pas à cause
du terrorisme organisé par par cuba mais
du fait de l'ineptie de seconde à son
président qui est on est dans la barre
la même idée ti en fait en quand il
s'agit de remettre cuba sur la la liste
des organisations qui parrainent le
terrorisme n'a rien pas beaucoup il ya
la corée du nord à l'iran et à la syrie
jusqu'à peu il y avait le soudan mais le
soudan a reconnu l'état d'israël donc il
n'est plus sur la liste des états
terroristes voyez ça tient pas à grand
chose et en réalité le jeu des mac
pompéo qui a pris ses distances avec
trump mec est toujours dans la même
ligne la belgique politique c'est en
gros ou déjà de deux mètres à des
obstacles devant la politique de bayonne
qui sont doute souhaiterait reprendre
celle qu'avait qu'avait mise en oeuvre
barack obama et qui avait retrouvé des
des relations correctes et normal avec
avec cuba et puis c'est aussi parce que
même si tron pour sait pas trop ce qui
va devenir mais je veux dire le le
combat politique entre démocrates et
républicains va continuer c'est aussi un
gage aux électeurs de floride hawks avec
la floride a été un des états les états
clés de la dernière élection et 30
d'avoir porté de très peu et pour les
prochaines élections qui ont lieu dans
quatre ans ou dans deux ans ou dans cinq
angles en six ans il faut garder cet
électorat pour les républicains
que penser de cette accusation états
soutenant le terrorisme sur quoi se base
t elle alors il se base vous allez voir
c'est complètement absurde en réalité se
base sur deux éléments principalement le
premier élément c'est la présence à cuba
de guérilleros colombiens
alors vous savez il y avait en colombie
de guérilla principal les forces armées
révolutionnaires de colombie qui ont
signé un accord de paix en
16 et puis il ya une deuxième guérilla
qui s'appelle l'armée de libération
nationale qui elle est toujours en
activité et qui avait entamé des
négociations avec le gouvernement
colombien
il se trouve que cuba a prêté son
territoire pour des lieux ces
négociations et le président d'extrême
droite talibane bouquet qui est un grand
ami d'ailleurs de dan trotte a rompu les
négociations avec cuba il a demandé à
cuba dextraze et les dirigeants de la
guérilla et de les extrader vers la
colombie c'est une âme une absurdité
totale on peut pas extrader les gens qui
sont dus pour négocier et évidemment
cuba a refusé et puis il ya un deuxième
élément c'est que les etats-unis
reprochent à cuba son appui au venezuela
du président nicholas réseau vous savez
la situation qui entre le venezuela et
les états unis en prétendant que en
aidant le venezuela cuba favorise la
présence de terroristes sur le
territoire benes audience qui est
évidemment une oeuvre une aberration
quelles conséquences pour à cuba ce que
cela peut compliquer les futures
relations entre cuba et joe biden bah ça
va on imagine en qu'abidal est
l'intention de normaliser les relations
avec cuba ça va lui compliquer la seule
venue compliquer la situation parce que
il peut pas revenir d'un trait de crayon
sur une décision comme ça qui est une
décision du département d'état il faudra
une révision formelle de ce placement
sur les listes héroïsme département
d'état ça prendra du temps et évidemment
ça va ça va poser des difficultés
supplémentaires pour cuba c'est la
poursuite d'une guerre d'agression la
même guerre d'agression que celle qui a
lieu contre le venezuela puisqu'un trump
a renforcé le ce qu'on appelle le blocus
à l'embargo qui dort depuis maintenant
60 ans avec l'objectif très clair
d'asphyxier l'économie de l'île
il a il a interdit les croisières il a
interdit les vols il vient de prendre
des mesures récentes et donc dans un an
plus dans une période de pandémie pour
port cuba par exemple qu'il ya des
problèmes pour se faire livrer du
pétrole du fait de ce blocus des états
unis on est un pays de 11 millions
d'habitants sans carburant c'est
quasiment un acte de piraterie est par
ailleurs à cuba la fin ce 1er janvier du
système de double monnaies est ce que
cela peut attirer
les investisseurs étrangers les
touristes sur l'île et donc peut-être
faire revenir les devises et donner du
baume au coeur à lille
alors si le 7 sept
cette réforme de l'amener là pour le
coup l'avenir nous dira d'abord quel
quelles conséquences ça va avoir sur la
population cubaine
en ce qui concerne le retour des
investisseurs étrangers mais là encore
on est on est quand même dépendant de la
politique des états unis dans la mesure
où un certain nombre d'entreprises
n'osent pas ou ne veulent pas ou ne
peuvent pas travailler avec cuba parce
que il tombe sous le coup des sanctions
des sanctions les états unis où vous
savez que c'est maintenant une
vous évoquiez tout à l'heure avec la
sphère du var en france mais ya pas que
ça je veux dire via le gazoduc north
stream nov une deux qui doivent
l'approvisionner en gaz russe
l'allemagne qui est l'objet de sanctions
il ya là le venezuela le biais de
sanctions
on est face à une politique d'autres
hommes qui est extrêmement brutal la
question qui se pose c'est est-ce que
bayonne va l'assouplir l'adoucir et
est-ce qu'il va reprendre une politique
plus plus humaine et plus consensuelle
par rapport à la communauté
internationale on imagine que c'est une
décision qui tombe évidemment mal dans
un contexte est également difficile à
cuba par difficile par évidemment la
crise sanitaire
balou cuba du temps telle manière j'irai
cuba est habitué à l'hostilité des
etats-unis l'hostilité de trump il faut
aussi rappeler quand même que des pays
comme cuba levée cela ne sont pas
complètement isolé puisqu'il s'en
trouver des alliés dans leur précisément
dans la communauté internationale avec
la russie avec l'iran avec un certain
nombre de pays mais évidemment ça ne
fait qu'ajouter aux difficultés de de
cuba qui a les difficultés économiques
et comme tous les pays du monde qu'on me
confronter à la pandémie est évidemment
c'est ces mesures sont complètement non
seulement stupide mais
posent les problèmes y compris il
comprit aabye donne un qui va devoir
gérer cette difficulté supplémentaire
merci beaucoup maurice lemoine
journaliste spécialiste de l'amérique
latine et dans le reste de l'actualité
on prend la direction de la république
centrafricaine deux semaines après les
élections le pays traverse une crise
politique et sécuritaire un moment
compliqué pour les habitants de la
capitale bangui qui doivent faire appel
à de nouveaux acteurs pour garantir leur
sécurité
reportage signé pas comme pâques angie
avec le récit de julien viaud aucune
aide n'est négligeable dans un contexte
aussi tendu en centrafrique
on essaye tant bien que mal de repousser
les attaques des rebelles après une
présidentielle mouvementée à bangui des
entreprises de sécurité privées sont
sollicités afin de maintenir l'ordre
dans la capitale centrafricaine
parmi les agents mobilisés figure roger
patrick rodrigue un homme travaillant
pour la société phoque sécurité ce
dernier va avant tout protéger la
population
[Applaudissements]
si d'avoir une vocation dû avoir un
objectif
celui de protéger le bien matériel
physique des agents enfin de personnes
auxquelles vous travaillez donc en un
mot vous assurer la sécurité
cette nuit la mission de roger patrick
et de ses collègues sera de protéger un
bar chic de bangui alors que le conflit
menace à tout moment la capitale
plusieurs établissements n'hésitent pas
à faire appel à ses agents l'objectif
pour vivre la patronne du bar garantir
la sécurité de ses clients et assurer la
pérennité de son entreprise
on a besoin vraiment d'avoir des gens de
sécurité pour déjà pour la sécurité de
mes clients moi j'ai des clients qui
arrivent c'est des clients des hautes
personnalités et des clients quand peur
de sortir
donc voilà on a fait appel à sa pour
leur assurer notamment une mission bien
loin des zones de combat mais qui a tout
de même son importance si à première vue
renforcer la sécurité d'un bar pendant
la nuit ne semble pas extraordinaire
roger patrick a une manière bien à lui
pour motiver des jeunes recrues à le
rejoindre
je leur dirai qu'il appelle son métier
ce métier que j'exerce j'en suis fier
j'ai vu des ça je leur demande de venir
au pas de moi je leur donner les
orientations possibles
l'excès ce soir la mission a été
parfaitement accompli par roger patrick
et ses collègues
les clients de vivies n'ont pu profiter
d'un moment dans son bar en toute
sécurité en eau ganda les opérateurs
internet sommet de suspendre l'accès aux
réseaux sociaux et aux services de
messagerie jusqu'à nouvel ordre
une injonction du gouvernement à deux
jours d'élections présidentielle et
législatives à haut risque le président
sortant avait nié âgé de 76 ans est au
pouvoir depuis 1986 françois xavier
lambert le calme règne encore dans les
rues de kampala la capitale ougandaise
mais derrière les apparences c'est un
scrutin mouvementée qui se joue dans le
pays pour les dix candidats qui défient
le président sortant yoweri musevini la
campagne a été éprouvante arrestations
menaces militants visés par des tirs de
gaz lacrymogènes ou à balles réelles et
maintenant la censure la commission
ougandaise des communications a ordonné
aux opérateurs de suspendre l'accès à
l'ensemble des réseaux sociaux et
services de messagerie notamment
facebook twitter whatsapp et viber l'onu
fait part de son inquiétude
le secrétaire général de l'onu encourage
également tous les acteurs politiques et
leurs partisans à s'engager publiquement
à mener leurs activités politiques de
manière pacifique et à s'abstenir de
toute incitation à la violence ou à des
discours de haine
face aux critiques de l'opposition et
aux craintes de la communauté
internationale sur la transparence du
scrutin le président moussavi ni affiche
sa sérénité
pour lui son âge 76 ans est un avantage
face à l'inexpérience de ses rivaux
quand il s'agit de diriger la société ou
toute autre chose il faut déjà avoir les
idées et des connaissances c'est ça
diriger les idées et la connaissance
l'âge joue aussi mais le plus important
ce sont les idées au pouvoir depuis
trente cinq ans le président ougandais
est parvenu à fusionner l'état avec son
parti le mouvement pour la résistance
nationale ce qui lui a permis pendant
toutes ces années de ne jamais perdre la
moindre élection mais cette fois un
adversaire se détache
obiwine 38 ans arrêté plusieurs fois
depuis 2018
pour cet ancien chanteur le pouvoir
ougandais fait tout son possible pour
étouffer l'opposition
comme vous le savez tous mesdames et
messieurs s'opposer au général mous
sévigny est un crime plus dangereux que
tout autre crime que nous connaissons
ici en ouganda alors que nous sommes ici
aujourd'hui
les enlèvements les tueries et les
arrestations se poursuivent
face au président sortant bobby brown de
son vrai nom robert cagoule annie compte
sur la mobilisation de la jeunesse dans
un pays où l'âge médian est inférieure à
16 ans près de 18 millions d'électeurs
ougandais sont appelés aux urnes
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi on se retrouve dans
quelques instants pour un point complet
sur l'actualité de la journée
[Musique]
bien sûr il ya des choses qui changent
bien sûr le monde change
il a d'ailleurs changé entre l'enfance
du général de gaulle et 1969
ce qui ne change pas c'est la condition
humaine et une certaine idée que la
civilisation se fait de la dignité de la
personne humaine et de sa liberté si
vous aviez deux ou trois mots pour
caractériser ce que vous appelez la
méthode l'attitude l'art de gouverner
vous diriez quoi tout d'abord
l'indépendance de la nation
ensuite la souveraineté du peuple et
enfin une conception de la france une et
indivisible
appuyez sur la fierté nationale devons
réapprendre à dire non comme disait
malraux seul l'esclave dit toujours oui
c'est ça la réinfection dessus du bureau
de chaque responsable politique en
particulier de ceux qui se prétendent
des hommes d'état
[Musique]
c'est au tour
certains disent que nous sommes pas une
chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme je monte sur les pas en
appartement on est énervé donnait le
sentiment qu'il faut à chaque fois se
battre ils vivent parfois au bord des
routes nationales pas forcément au loin
de paris mais toujours loin de ceux qui
les dirigent
moi j'adhère mâcon il passe un tour de
tracteur et cnooc est en campagne il
faut savoir c'est qu'une vie différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles ma forêt td quoi un peu plus
aujourd'hui la france oubliée c'est
montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]